three
two
we are live this is the h3 podcast it is
april 8th we are here with brittany
broski we have a
thank
guest
thank you for being here
it's nice to have a guest in the studio
yeah glad to be here um
no i got to thank my sponsor really fast
so
uh if you could just look in the camera
and say i'm just kidding
we actually brought you here to work i
keep trying to get brittany to do uh ad
reads for me
yeah we're gonna get me to sign a w-2 as
well yeah yeah
okay so dan it says pre-roll but this is
a full ass copy read for mint mobile hmm
well
you want me to do a full copy read right
now let's just do a little little mini
one
just summarize yo guys
yo guys mint mobile is insane uh how
could i get do this whole coffee it's
supposed to be 15 seconds and it's like
a full minute ad read it really fast
if someone on this video was what are
you stop closing twenty three why are
you supposed to speak
personally i'm about to go by mint
mobile yeah
guys mint mobile is 15 bucks a month and
it's just as good as all the other big
boys you can get a you can get it
shipped right to your door keep the same
number blah blah blah you know the deal
go to mintmobile.com
after dark it's 15 bucks a month that's
mimo.com after dark cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month mintmobile.com
after dark all right well thanks for
being here brittany
how are you
you know
actually my genuine answer is fantastic
really these past few months have been
some of the happiest of my life isn't
that sweet
interesting
how have you been
oh terrible
horrible last few months have been the
worst of my life well that sucks for you
i heard you were a good mythical morning
uh this morning and that's unacceptable
to me what's going on
i don't know what that is i have oh is
that a secret
oh [ __ ] i don't i don't know no they
don't care no i didn't sign anything
yeah but i love goodness good morning
but i'm just like you can't you can't be
doing rhett and link before this show
because their office is so clean and
nice and good and everyone they're so
professional you're going to come in
here and you're going to do a 180 and
leave they give you a gift basket
give the [ __ ] i give you a diet coke hey
you gave me teddy fresh right
i brought my rick and morty um sweatsuit
with me even though it's 98 degrees yeah
it's so hot
yeah those guys are nice right they're
tall and handsome and skinny smell good
how are they so skinny they're like
skinny like link does sit ups for sure i
i could not tell you and link has some
of the greatest hair i've ever what yeah
it's insane they're both in their 40s
yeah dude rival hairline king rival
hairline so people call me the hairline
king got a great hairline
now
whose is better lynx are mine you can't
pit two beautiful men against each other
i'm not gonna do that on the podcast
thank you we will pull it up
oh my god look up link neil hair 2022
yo that hairline is insane bro he's got
that um
that david lynch yeah look at that at
the the yeah you know what you know what
get off the screen i can't do this
it's too painful
i feel that this is actually a new setup
we've got here that i was kind of
enjoying because there's the skinny shot
show the skinny shoddy in
and then show the fat shot
hey guys this is ethan fat ethan
skinny ethan
fat ethan gonna talk about which
trimester you're in later
third at least i mean that's that's all
of them so tell me about you so you've
been in la for how long now well i moved
to l.a right before the [ __ ] pandemic
like okay december 2019 i was gone for
all of february of 2020 and then i came
for playlists i was at playlist we
immediately came back to la and
everything shut down
so i feel robbed of the genuine la
experience
and it's interesting now because i've
been here for two years three years
almost and i'm just recently you know
like meeting all these people that i've
you know
been following online for so long
and it's an interesting thing to put
like personalities to faces it's it's
cool that hollywood is so
i want to talk about this i have so much
i want to talk about okay well um go
ahead i'm going to use my podcast
this is the new age of hollywood would
you agree
what like the podcasters would you
forever
have taken over yeah
yeah i mean in la there's so much young
young new media stars yeah definitely i
mean especially in 10 years when all
these little kids grow up yes yeah
they'd be like they'll be like who
slapped you right
it's even [ __ ] like you know people
don't
these gin alphers don't you bring up
leonardo dicaprio johnny depp they're
like who
like what do you mean who that's wild
like the
how
a-list celebrities used to run the world
now it's this generation of like the
tana mojos and bryce halls as
problematic as they are they're
constantly in the news people for some
reason give a [ __ ] what they're doing
right it's wild to think about like
that's the new we're rushing in a new
age so that's you you're on the
forefront
man i don't know
so you're in la you're meeting
people you're grooving i mean the
pandemic is kind of winding down yeah
are you doing any fun
time yeah a little bit they're saying
they're saying it's coming back you guys
seen that
no
i've seen some i follow epidemiologists
on twitter and they're like it's coming
back you guys we're they always say they
go we're sleepwalking into a disaster
that's so scary
yeah that language is so sweet we're
asleep aren't we all we're all
sleepwalking into our death
19.
that's kenneth copeland by the way cool
don't know who that is
oh he's the guy who yeah whatever it's
all good story okay
yeah so um
that brittany i want to ask you a
question can women be funny
i'm just kidding
i'm just kidding but you hear that [ __ ]
all the time on the internet right
yeah a good you know what though my
following is all the girls and the gays
and the days
and so
the girls the gays in the days yeah the
holy trinity and so i very rarely
interact with straight men and straight
men are the ones that say that
so i really don't get a lot of those
comments but i see it you know like
there are so many
famous funny women
coming from tick tock like caitlyn riley
do you know her
she does a bunch of characters on tiktok
and instagram and like i see that in her
comments like women aren't funny i'm
like did you watch the video yeah
objectively it's pretty funny well i am
just like your mom your mom hurt you so
bad i'm so sorry i'm sorry your mother
didn't hug you i wish that one lady even
though that lady was like i wish i could
have been a good mother to you putin
i wish she was your mom man
yeah then you would find women funny but
i've noticed on tick tock i always get
these videos they're like this is me
watching uh female comedians until i
laugh and they're just sitting there
like
it's like bro those are the same dudes
that if you draw a [ __ ] and balls on a
table they'll be like
good
harry's so true penis
they're giggling they're giggling yeah
it's true so there you go women can be
funny you heard it here i think yeah
that's the final verdict i mean i
married one
hey how bad can they be
[Applause]
you know
that should be your slogan
how bad can they be women i married one
hey my kids got a mom
you know ela couldn't be here today um
she's usually here but our nanny called
in she has diarrhea or nanny
diarrhea
you know what that's a valid excuse yeah
actually my son has diarrhea too he came
in
to our more our bedroom at 4 am
how old is he now he's uh
almost three oh wow
yes
and um he went into he goes daddy have
to pee i think he's embarrassed about
pooping for some reason
yeah
and so he goes in and then he does this
thing where he goes daddy i need privacy
so i say okay
but he just he it was gnarly bro like a
big fat nasty diarrhea at 4am
and i don't know if you're looking to
being a parent or if that's something
you're interested in doing one day at
any time soon yeah this is solidifying
that for me yeah so at 4am i was i had a
uh
clorox wipe and i was wiping [ __ ] out of
a
out of a little uh potty oh i guess
that's yeah because he's not on the big
toilet nope it'd fall in
yes he would he would just like me i'm
so skinny and tiny sometimes i just fall
into the toilet yeah help me help me i'm
swimming around so that's what that's
what ela's doing
so um tell me
is it true that your first thing your
first big break was this kombucha thing
did that really put you on the map
it was
that was august 2019 and i knew that
because i've been on the internet
chronically
it's a problem since i was a child
i knew that like
the nature of going viral
you have literally 15 minutes of fame
and then it's gone and you choose what
you do with that and so i knew that all
these eyes were on me and i did not want
to be pigeonholed into that one thing
and so as people were following me and
you know accounts were crediting me for
using the image and the video
um first of all i was putting tick tock
on the map because it had the watermark
on it people didn't know what tik-tok
was really this was like it was not
widespread mainstream at all at this
point
so people were like what is this logo
all these articles were like it's a
viral tick-tock what the [ __ ] is that
and so i'm it's cool to be a part of the
tick tock story
and then at the same time i started
posting videos on twitter instagram tick
tock youtube
of just other stuff i was doing you know
accents skits impressions
and there was one day in august of 2019
where i gained 96 000 twitter followers
in 24 hours
wow it's like it's like
the actual
when you think about how many accounts
the meme was reaching and how many
people really saw that video it was
global i was seeing like climate change
posters in new zealand with my face on
it like the meme in russian in arabic
and you know
wahili it was insane like all these
things were being sent to me and i was
like holy [ __ ]
it was cool
that's awesome and so i mean you really
turned the the meme into a career which
i i don't think is easy to do it's not
and i [ __ ] hate when people call me
kombucha girl now
uh-oh it's like you know what i mean
it's like i've done so much since then
but that's okay like people call me vape
nation guys still and it's sure
it's like thanks for it's like hey
yeah you're the guy yeah
when you're on the street what do people
say to you when they come up to you
they well i don't get vape nation that
much anymore i don't know if you know
the whole vape nation thing yeah
because for a long time that was
that was you know
all i got it's been a while though i
still get it sometimes but i think it's
mostly just like hey ethan
yeah they feel like they're yeah you're
their friend i love that
i say [ __ ]
i say call me sir you [ __ ] little
dude call me loud
kiss the ring as it's [ __ ]
yeah that's i mean usually i just push
their face away right i don't say
anything right yeah just physical
assault yeah just violence you get the
kombucha thing though no i it's
the people that do it to me are straight
men when i'm at like those [ __ ] i'm
serious because they never all my
content is okay can you not man excuse
me
i'm just that's a very expensive uh you
know what i want to take a moment to say
that i'm on my post malone world tour
because i was on good mythical morning
this morning and now oh yeah
yeah and i'm literally like living my
postman fantasy yeah so i i just had to
have to touch everything
so you this is the very table he's sad
at is that right guys
in fact some say you can smell it's it
still smells like cigarette if you want
to know that and bud like spilled bud
light when i start licking the table
later get the camera off and we even
have a little surprise for you
posty
no he's not here we do have a surprise
though go ahead is it ready
oh
we like to present our guests with a uh
personalized present yeah okay
we've been working the tires tirelessly
well not us but kids in a sweat factory
in india we outsource this right right
if you see blood on the fingertips don't
look at it too no i'm just kidding ian
made this
[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's look
sam is our prop master she made this
it is this is really impressive so wait
can you can you guys see it
it's a life it's a life-size cutout of
harry styles cowboyed up
it's a combination of every all the
things you like all right let's read
this
first of all great cowboy huh absolutely
fantastic
texas flag quite a glare here let me see
so there you go
he's so beautiful
we've got a bernie 20
sticker i support science human rights
public education affordable health care
immigrants and refugees for your speech
but god damn we got we just put
everything yeah i do support if there's
anything in there you don't like we can
sharpie it out blur it yeah
this is great so there you go you know
uh he's cowboy harry styles
happy to have you is that your perfect
man right there
um if he had a a little mustache yeah
he does well yeah he needs to grow that
up
you like the mustache i do i like a
mustache i grew a mustache i mean not
for you but
i appreciate that you got more of a
beard situation
yeah like a finely just clean mustache
yeah okay what's that about the tattoos
couldn't tell you
don't know it's a texas thing you grew
up in texas not even yeah i grew up i
grew up all over you want the life story
uh i mean we've got time
like well [ __ ] we're live yeah um i was
a military brat so i've lived all over
the u.s i lived in south korea
okay interesting bts stan do you stand
bts yeah i like bts um try that again
you better you better well no because if
i say i'm a stan then that implies that
like i have stand level knowledge which
i don't but i enjoy their music and i
enjoy the i enjoy a group okay i just
group dynamics got to make sure because
i don't want any trouble coming your way
and tay is my favorite okay everyone
shut up
i i just do this to cover my base i say
please just don't kill me
don't come to my house please don't send
this don't email my sponsors just leave
me the [ __ ] alone
we stay on bts forever
butter baby you got it yeah
it's like ha ha butter chip
so yeah tell me your life story so you
grew up your your
parent which one of your parents is in
the military my dad what's he do air
force he flies pilot what's he fly 18's
what's that it's a plane
it's an airplane it's a fighter jet oh
[ __ ] okay pretty cool does he do speed
well he didn't do that um anymore he
flew attends and then he was a a trainer
for nato students it's pretty cool so
we've lived all over the southeastern
united states did a stint south korea
and then he retired and i think 2014.
so
he works in florida now
and he's doing some kind of like
training in florida yeah now he does
some form of like um
sorry dad you're listening he's not um
he does some form of
he's the liaison between the
engineers who design the software that
goes into the planes and the pilots that
fly him because he can speak both
languages it's pretty cool wow that is
really cool
and so
you are basically and then you grew up
in on military bases not really no we
grew up in cities but my dad would
commute that's a dismal exp like
existence living on a military base
really i thought i thought that's just
what it was i guess it depends on what
country you're in
yeah in south korea we had the option to
live on base but we didn't we lived in
like seoul in the city and like a
high-rise apartment building and it was
cool i rode the bus to school every day
with a bunch of like little korean kids
wow it was a blast and so how long did
you live in seoul a year
okay yeah so
like the majority where did you grow up
there is no majority we never did more
than four years in one place but i say
i'm from texas because my whole mom's
side of the family's from texas and i
did i spent a lot of time how does that
actually affect you growing up though
where you're moving around all the time
you don't have roots great social skills
you think so yeah
because my impression of you was the
opposite
and they tell me that a lot you're hard
to be around right hard to look at
that's dysfunctional hard to talk to
yeah i get that a lot
so you you're forced to be able to make
friends wherever you go yeah well that's
good it's a great skill to develop that
actually yeah yeah
what about you
well i want to i will grow up in the
same place and i have terrible social
skills i i don't like making friends i
don't have friends
but i mean you're in the job of
entertainment so you got to have
you know you got to be able to market
yourself and all that yeah
i don't know i grew up in a small town
ventura which is near here in socal into
a highway
yeah
you know that song no
yeah but yeah all right
my parents both worked all the time i'm
the youngest i basically raised myself
you know i was home by myself all day we
can tell
yeah exactly
yeah
and that's interesting so you
as a child you had a lot of hobbies
i play video games a hobby it's biggest
yeah that's why is that here dan why is
this fly here that fly is so big what
there's a giant fly how am i supposed to
do a [ __ ] bug
it was all britney's rider
that's my pet that was your ride no on a
rider she requested
she you fit on that have a little leash
i told you i'm so tiny i fall into a
toilet big fly but damn
so you
and then did you want to always be in
entertainment what was your deal before
that no as a child i wanted to be a
marine biologist yeah we all did right
george costanza fan
um no is that from seinfeld yeah no
my dad was
um i grew up
i said i [ __ ] love dolphins oh my god
i love dolphins can i tell you something
yeah
there's people that jerk off dolphins
like i've seen a video on the internet
they don't
i saw something what videos are you
watching well
i'm just saying like there's weird [ __ ]
that goes like i think it was on
like where did i see that live leak
maybe someone gets paid to do that yeah
i just had a realization yeah zach's our
sound guy
that's wild can you google do dolphins
why do dolphin have penis remember that
video why don't i have people they're
mammal how else do they have sex
magic
you're the biologist you tell me
you're the breed you're the one obsessed
with dolphins uh goddamn wait do
dolphins have a penis someone fact check
that i mean they must yeah of course
they do yeah they're a mammal
show me a picture okay i know there's
dolphin vaginas i know that forever uh
dude what dude let's switch to the
screen ian
yeah there's a fatty eel so there's a
fat dolphin [ __ ] for you
[Laughter]
yeah i got banned from twitter because i
tweeted a picture of spirit the horse
with this [ __ ] out
oh you sweet you got bad for tweeting a
horse cop they deleted my account
because i tweeted horse talk what i said
spirit is so hot
they deleted me
they're not down with the bestiality
[ __ ] they're not down for it that is the
craziest thing i've seen all day yes so
i was on live leak
and uh they have this like gamble
feature there was a moment where i
stopped going to that website
but you just click and click and it was
like a person
having a relation with a dolphin and it
deeply disturbed me i carry that
that the shame of having saw that even
to this day i'm not kidding this is part
of your story it is it's part of who i
am
yeah there'll be a moment of me just
dramatic music
i'm just
this is the moment whenever you change
yeah yeah
yeah so dolphins do have penises go on
um anyway love dolphins
um
how much do you love dolphins not that
much okay not enough to know what their
genitalia looks like what if you would
ask me and i was like let me tell you
actually it's interesting
i have some pictures saved would you
like to see them sure um
i want to be a rare biologist and then i
went to school for
i wanted to make super bowl commercials
that was my i wanted to be like a
copywriter but like
like i wanted to make geico commercials
that was what i wanted to do there i as
a child was like those are so funny and
they're so well done the geico gecko the
caveman
um
um flo from progressive like those are
iconic marketing campaigns and i wanted
to be a part of that because i was like
i want to incorporate humor into my job
without
the
whatever it is of like
going for it like i'm going to move to
hollywood and moved to new york because
i was realistic you know i was like
people moved to hollywood with a hundred
dollars in their pocket and think
they're gonna make it and i was like
that's not
i'm not trying to do that so i went to
college for
communication
um graduated worked in insurance hated
it worked at a bank hated it and then
got fired because of the meme
wait yeah i read that you got fired
where were you working at the time i
worked i was in dallas and i was working
in trust and investment services our
clients were like 85 and up these were
people it was like estate planning like
people that were about to die and had a
bunch of money
like who the [ __ ] cares and so you you
blew up for this this this meme which by
the way wasn't like
edgy it was just like goofy face the
comment the captions though
my 60 year old boss
you didn't make yeah just like she was
seeing
me when i tasted [ __ ] for the first time
right and thinking it's
little britney at her desk being like
this will kill him
like it wasn't that at all but trying to
explain that to her
it was kind of useless because she had
made up her mind about you know this is
a bad look for the company and
so they fired you for this meme i wonder
if that's is that legal well in texas
it's an at-will employment state which
texas is like i'll fire you texas said
or any damn no literally if you're ugly
they could fire you in the first 90 days
they're like you know what i don't like
looking at you every day right you can't
sue them because the first 90 days it's
completely up to you was it in the first
90 days around the 89th day oh really
slick yeah it was awful but i think
things happen for a reason because i
never really worked out but damn yeah i
never would have taken this as a serious
career move you know and now i'm i'm i'm
serious i'm
i recognize how lucky i am like for all
this to have worked out i'm just so
happy what a what an interesting
blessing in disguise they fire you on
your 89th day and then you said to
yourself you know i'm just gonna go
after this i applied dialback steakhouse
oh you immediately were like [ __ ] it out
i was humiliated i called my dad crying
i was like i lost my bank job but i'm
about to go apply it out back and then
i'm gonna get another job i'm so sorry
and he was like it's okay
and then i got my first brand deal right
after that with a kombucha company so
you never went to outback never never
had a kombucha deal did you have to say
you liked it because we were not still
not sure if you liked it or not yeah i
got paid to endorse it yeah
and now i'm free of those contracts and
i so can you say did you like the
kombucha no okay you hate it did you
watch the video it's gross well you i
think the vertical well right you did
definitively say no you don't like it
yeah it's bad i actually do like
kombucha you do is that for not bad is
that for attention
well somebody likes somebody's buying it
or everyone's lying because it tastes
like you're sucking on someone's big toe
it tastes like beer you love beer i
don't like beer
oh
you be like come on all the time i have
bad i have bad intel
no i don't i don't like the taste of
beer it's yeasty kombucha's yeasty
that's what she said
we don't have a sound effect for that
attack
okay
you might want to see a doctor about
that
yeasty
imagine being described as beastie oh
that's ethan he's nice but he's a little
yeasty he's a good guy but yeasty
he gives yeast yeah
giving essence of yeast
so we did we got the uh so how much you
get your first brando seven thousand
dollars holy [ __ ] but that was that's
amazing not including
well that included like the flight the
hotel oh damn what the [ __ ] they have
you do out of it and then the people
that brought me it were taking 20 from
me wait hold the phone hold on hold on
what kind of deal was this
it was to come film a video
with
someone from the company
and
that was the flat fee
it will give you seven thousand
and then you have to book your own
travel all this and then with the course
the agency took 20
from me what agency negotiated that
dumbass deal i'm gonna say because i
sued them but you did yes
there's a whole dark side of this whole
industry oh i know that well i don't
work with anyone i don't work with
agency well actually there's one agency
i work with on this podcast because i
love them and i've had a long word but
managers agencies it's all [ __ ] i
[ __ ] hate them all you've been in the
business long enough to know that though
yeah you know like people don't know
that especially these tick talkers like
i remember
when
in late 2019 when everyone was like
i have a million followers
i'm rich and famous and that's like no
because p these they come in like
vultures
well part of the problem is that you
have traditional media which oh my god
is that a new language can i get one of
these i can't be she can't be burping
over me
thank you baby this is bubbles going
straight to my brain yo can i tell you
that that coke there's something about
coke zero that slaps like diet coke [ __ ]
you diet coke is dead to me
yeah [ __ ] dc wake up with a dc i'm
not i'm about to shave 10 years off my
life for coke zero i'll give anything
for it
zero
they always say uh sugar is what'll kill
us [ __ ] take me thanks bro well
there's no sugar in this well but it has
that fake sugar taste oh that's
definitely some chemical that tastes
like sweet which is [ __ ] crazy pump
it in my veins put it in the iv [ __ ]
yeah these are delicious
cheers
this is not sponsored by coca-cola but i
do have a coke tattoo
oh wow
do you like coke that much of coke
i don't like it that much
it's more an aesthetic thing just saying
you're like you're a freak and you need
to be stopped
[Music]
that scared the [ __ ] out of me i forgot
someone was behind me
you didn't let it flip that
you're embarrassing us either yeah
hey uh zach can you do me a favor and
not play pig sounds when we have a guest
that was a burp okay thanks i thought
you're
like
trying to make her feel welcome okay
playing pig calls when i come in yeah uh
zach please thank you
[Laughter]
yeah i go zach okay so when she sits
down play all the pig and the styes
that's good that's good you got anything
else you want to humiliate our guests
with zach yeah throw it at me i think
i'm done now
just for the record it was a burp
so uh what were we talking about um
oh eight
agencies and oh yeah so the thing is you
know you think of traditional media you
go these they all have agents and
lawyers and
managers these people actually do stuff
in that business
in this business they basically
piggybacking on the reputation of
traditional
managements
and basically do
nothing for you and taking what's you
know there's laws to protect traditional
it's funny it's like age it's like
actors they really need laws protecting
them there's like 10 of them there's
like 10 working actors somehow they have
laws being like you can only charge 10
the rest is is uh
you know i've always said this is the
wild west the internet is the wild west
right now like before
people start really cracking down on
like
even when it comes to like family
vloggers and things like that
filming a child from the point when
they're born to when they're 18 that's
gonna that has ethical implications
there is no child protection laws for
youtubers and in traditional media oh
yeah yeah the temples of the world yeah
you can't overwork them you can't
overwork them you need to make sure they
educate them properly there's oversight
you know but ryan toy's review would be
like
you know
this is great dad i get i don't have to
go to school and i play with toys all
day yeah and then fast forward ryan's
doing 20 years for uh
what god's name is that [ __ ] i left
hearing about it this is a new one this
is daddy dello tv
uh i left our two-year-old baby alone in
the car bad idea here's his two-year-old
i think looks like he's dying of heat
stroke and the mommy is outside
screaming he needs air and he's
screaming help yeah that's a thumbnail
yep why is that a th why is that why
does that exist
it's a common theme with these fans hold
that up i want to watch it well it has
no i sure there's nothing to do with it
that's what i'm saying is like this is
all click bait but people are going to
watch it because they're like
a bad mother i'm going to leave a hate
comment and they don't even watch the
video and they're like you [ __ ]
that's a baby
i i do think that
a bunch of laws are gonna in the next 10
20 years or
even earlier
to crack down on kind of what's going on
specifically youtube because
it's insane
well actually there was even
a recent development where
um here's the video by the way
before there's like
there's advertising laws for kids yeah
and youtube was like well [ __ ] that we
don't need to worry about that like you
can't they're you can't advertise to
kids in certain ways there's laws
because they don't know that they're
they're watching an ad right but they're
coerced and so
youtube was just ignoring those laws for
like the beginning and then just like
last year now you have to click is this
video made for kids yeah but you gotta
love that youtube's like
oh no that doesn't apply to us [ __ ]
these kids it's until it's the last
moment where it's like
people are raising enough of a fuss that
you need to be like all right we'll make
some changes that's what it is i think
like
things like the ace family and all that
that's gonna be
taboo over the next few years make your
money now i'm saying you got some kids
put them on camera now i know five years
can't do it i got prime kids i gotta put
them on camera now but i'm sure you all
have talked about that how how much are
you going to film not at all not at all
no no not at all in fact i'm not even
comfortable showing my i'm comfortable
showing like i just have a newborn baby
who's two months right because he he
doesn't look anything like he's going to
but my son who's almost three now i
don't want people to know what he looks
like because i'm paranoid someone's
gonna [ __ ] kidnap him from school
yeah
i did make a tick tock with him the
other day but there was a uh filter on
it
he looked like the joker
that's the first time i've showed his
face in in a while
here you want to see it it's really cute
yeah i do
thanks thanks for saying that yeah
thanks for agreeing can we watch it
three times in a row
sure
oh there's alright now
i'm just gonna go to the end how am i
supposed to
uh
feed gotham
when every time i've got a child here
and i'll be well
i just i just like that
you tell them
the music you tell them
i just like the end when he's laughing
it's so cute it's cute but it's creepy
with him
he's pet he's bad he's the joker yeah
it's creepy why make him if he asks for
french fries and make him french fries
he doesn't eat the french fries you got
a creepy ass kid that's enough to make a
guy go mad
yeah so i agree you know yeah but the
problem
is that uh
well i i use these managers and [ __ ] and
you know
you realize after a while that they're
literally not doing anything but taking
twenty percent which again you're not
even supposed to take twenty percent you
just take ten percent the industry
standard is ten and even then it's like
girl i think they're wants to do 30 in
this space for any
up-and-coming
internet personality who's looking to do
this for a career i would say you need
an agent to secure you deals and you
need a lawyer
and when you get to a certain level you
need a business manager who will
monitor your funds invest them properly
things like that everything else is
completely these people have assistants
and managers you don't need a manager
i don't know i'm an accountant i mean
you don't need a yeah you don't even
need a well a business manager is kind
of a blanket term but yeah just someone
to do your taxes so you don't go to
[ __ ] jail definitely pay your taxes
and people don't know that they don't
know that you're supposed to because
you're self-employed yeah it's true the
crazy thing is like when you first start
making money on the internet you're like
i have all this money in my bank account
you don't yeah you know
sam's money brother
but so tell me about this kombucha deal
though because we got sidetracked and
i'm curious so
they say i'm gonna give you seven grand
but then your ass got to pay for
everything so you flew up i pay my team
you gotta pay your team after everything
was said and done i probably made about
i had about four thousand dollars in my
bank account
still good money it was great money and
i lived off that
to move to l.a
wow and it was
well i don't want to get into like the
specifics of it because it i did end up
suing them um
but yeah you have a agreement saying you
can't talk about it i just don't want to
yeah um but i'm signed a uta now and uta
is fantastic yeah they do they do my
deals now their digital side their
digital site and a bunch of other stuff
too we're assigned to um well trying to
ut overall but i have a touring
touring agent yeah for when sarah and i
are going to take the podcast on the
road
um and i do like college shows when they
do that i have a traditional agents and
like
uh stage acting and well you got the
whole i got everybody we have a podcast
agent um
and then of course digital so it's it's
wild
rodeo
i don't work with anybody
do you want to though no do you ever
want to take this beyond i mean have you
i'm sure you've thought about selling
this to a network why would i sell it to
a network i get my own ads i own
everything
more money
the only thing they're gonna do is take
money i guess i'm telling you those
people they're all vultures i guess
that's true welcome all fire them all
britney
i walk out of here with no
representation fire them all you're like
either just ruin my life
fire them all i think it takes a village
because if i had to do all that [ __ ] i
would have no energy to create
yeah my what i kind of learned was like
with a good um assistant they can do
everything so but i agree you don't want
to focus on anything but creating stuff
and that's i've i've set that up for
myself and i love it okay i get to just
do what i do yeah
but it they take a lot it does take a
village and i would
every time i've had to do like a
what would you give advice to your
younger self and be like you don't need
to you don't need all that
you don't need any of it
so
right
so um basically at this point i'm going
to need you to say i love native
now's the ad read i'm not getting paid
for i'm just kidding just pretend you
know i usually we usually have our
guests pre-recorded and i won't make you
sit through this but i have to thank our
sponsor it's just one so just pretend
you're not here for about one minute
okay can i go pee oh that's perfect yeah
yeah thank you
hey guys thanks to native
let me tell you a little bit about
native
amy's coming in he's training hard he's
applying that native thank you yeah dan
told me to sit in what is that is that
this is that's native right here so
deodorant oh eucalypt i love eucalyptus
smell it's legit the thoughtful
formulation behind all the products is
something i have always loved because
they understand it's not just what's on
the inside that counts but also the
outside that's why native is releasing
their deodorant
uh that i know and love
and new and improved plastic free is
that plastic free
i guess so well [ __ ] me in the ass
that's awesome
plastics are horrible native is doing
their part to help our earth with their
new 100 plastic free and recyclable
packaging and when you buy natives new
plastic free recyclable package
deodorant you are saving 37 grams of
plastic native is also a proud partner
of one percent for the planet
and are committing one percent of their
plastic free deodorant sales to the
environmental nonprofits
just like all of natives other
deodorants their plastic free deodorant
is aluminum and paraben free kills odor
causing bacteria and has 24-hour odor
protection to keep you feeling and
smelling fresh and with native
chews from 10 cents including classic
coconut vanilla sensitive formula
and a for and uh that are formulated
without baking soda
oh sensitive has no baking soda
and there's even an unscented one that's
really interesting you've been using
that
i have it's i've been using this before
it was actually even a sponsor really
yeah it's legit i like it it doesn't
burn for some reason like the other
brands burn and it lasts
i wear when i work out and you you train
hard and that could keep you from
sinking let me smell that
this isn't the one you use is it it is
the one i use i'm not gonna smell i'm
not gonna put that right on my face i'm
just being honest but yeah it smells
great but i mean that's that's that's
sort of legit i mean and it feels like
you've been using that too yeah i have
every day
thanks bro no problem with that
i'm gonna give britney her seat back now
yeah
by native
uh ready to try plastic free deodorant
go to native
native deal
native deo.com
after dark and use the promo code after
dark at checkout to get 20 off your
first order that's native d e o dot com
slash after darker use the promo code
after dark at checkout for 20 percent
off your first order thank you to native
okay
all right
[Music]
yes baby yes
no cut has been taken for parasitical
agents or managers
i agree
[ __ ]
yes so tell me um what are you into
lately what's your what's what are you
vibing on
um
i just recently discovered in my mid
twenties i like mushrooms
like eating them okay i was like okay no
not not like the drug but you're just
into eating mushrooms yeah yeah they're
good they're delicious i had no idea i
was like oh mushroom pizza crust they
are like one of the weirdest things the
texture is one of those things where
like it's almost inedible right but the
taste is delicious right
the once you get used to the texture
it's actually quite nice it's like chewy
and firm you like tofu
sometimes when it's prepared right yeah
i i can't do tofu it is kind of similar
to mushroom in it yeah mushrooms is just
so odd they're like not even like it's a
different branch of life it's not even
like normal plant [ __ ] yeah it's like
alien fruit it's different from how you
and i are yeasty because they're fungal
fungal or yeasty yeah
i think also
it's when you think about you know like
neanderthals
foraging and like nuts and berries and
all that to be like what's that
put in my mouth i know it grows out of
the floor they were so brave the
foragers and some of them make you see
like
dead people
ghosts and spirits do you like magic
mushrooms
never had them
are you straight uh straight edge as
they say not really i think um i just
have so much going on up here i'm very
scared of like acid osd shrooms yeah
scared of well don't don't do it i mean
it's not that big of a deal people be
like most rooms change my maybe and i'm
not to say that it didn't but i mean
it's not that big of a deal that meme
that's like
men do shrooms one time and discover
empathy i'm right
that's true
you go death bro life is so fragile
you've discovered empathy yeah you've
discovered caring for another human yeah
congrats welcome well hey a breakthrough
is a breakthrough
happy to have you
welcome to the planet
welcome to the show
um
and uh
and what is your problem with the term
meat candle
um
that ignites a nasty visceral response
in my body so
brittany
she has a problem with the term for a
penis being a meat candle now that's
just what i think my [ __ ] is just a meat
candle
and what shin do you like in fact i put
a candle in it and light it
use urethra torture
and i like the wax to go inside it's
just a terrible image no you're right
it's horrible that's god-awful i i heard
that and i said like immediately my day
was ruined
they said hey you're gonna take it hold
the meat candle i said
it ruined my day
because it's almost like a std it's like
why is it why is uh
why is flammable gas coming out of the
tip of your dick yeah
why is the tip of your penis blue
right a blue flame
i think it's gross i think that um
and i'm not [ __ ] on like pee pee poo
poo humor because that i love that
i love a good
draw penis i'll laugh you know play the
penis game in public i'm giggling
but something about that i was like wow
meat
meat candle it is foul it is
foul yeah
um
so should we do this taste test
well brittany you mentioned this
don't like the taste of beer
yeah i thought you liked beer yeah what
have i what indication have i given yeah
what indication is she given that she
likes beer so i guess you have some uh
tech talks where you were uh i guess you
were probably duetting or stitching
somebody that was doing a beer taste
test and you were doing it ironically
but maybe featherstone right we may have
been misled into thinking that that was
not ironic yeah so here's the story with
that rusty featherstone was this account
that went viral during the pandemic
it's this frat guy who is in maine and
he lives with all of his frat brothers
and so they were quarantining and he
started this trend where it's called
rusty ranks beers that's probably what
you're picking up on and they would buy
a 12 pack of a new brand of beer and he
just is the most frightened welcome back
to restaurants bears today we're going
to be drinking [ __ ]
like that's literally how he talks and
he would pick a brand he would do a
check in after four he'd be like i have
a foreign it's the kobe bryant of bears
phil and [ __ ] wall football the video
that surfer dude
and then at eight he would check in and
at 12 he's just blackout and he would be
like
a seven out of ten get you where you
want to go and i thought i binged his
whole account i sat there for two hours
watching all of his tick tocks and i was
like i have to do this and i did it with
white claw surges
which is white claw but worse just more
alcohol
worse taste
and i drank uh
five and blacked out and i don't
remember what happened
and i filmed that video we ended up
going to madison beer's birthday party
couldn't tell you really we got there
okay interesting um ended up there and i
remember filming i was like
i'm gonna finish my tick-tock and i had
my friend film me and i said i'm about
to britney ranks bears i'll give up not
in all time don't remember posting it
wow okay because we put testing we put
together a whole beer taste test
and i mean i'll do it and we got well we
got the worst tasting beers we could
find
so why would you do that
well we're gonna too because we prepared
but we got bad off we don't really don't
know if the yeah we we haven't tried
them yet what are some of the brands it
could be delicious
uh i don't know we just we kind of just
tried to get the most nasty they're not
brands
one is like a super sour
one is german smoked malt beer it's like
a liquid smoke flavor
which sounds
bad to me got a pickle beer
and we have a hard coffee beer
you want pickled beer i could we could
put some pickle juice in a beer for you
i would really drink that pickle beer is
delicious do we have pickled juice guys
i heard some dissenting from the peanut
gallery
a little put off by the pickle juice
idea but if you're into it i mean i love
a picture no judgment so you your
favorite men your two favorite men post
malone and harry styles right
um
the ranking changes daily
currently robert pattinson's in there
jack carlo is obviously a third okay um
um you have watched peaky blinders
mm-hmm killian murphy who plays shelby
is that the main guy who plays yeah
tommy shelby i like him he's got swag i
love him he was in my top five for a
while probably still is okay so this is
interesting
because he you know he's kind of a
badass in that but in real life i think
he's a gentle he's a fine gentleman he's
very shy yeah he's an irish gentleman
and he's very shy in interviews and
stuff he's one of those people that's
like so awkward but he comes alive
acting
and what does that say about him is he
sociopath
no i think he's just uh he's just a shy
guy what does it mean to be a good actor
you're lying i don't know yeah actors
are i tend to be weird people right like
they're always they're
want to be someone else constantly you
got a problem you're a [ __ ] weirdo
you like that
yeah you like damaged men i love a
broken man okay yeah
have you thought about why like what is
that because i i'm certainly you're not
alone is it is it a bad boy thing you're
into no it is um i think at the end of
the day it's an egocentric thing because
i am a problem solver okay and i see a
broken man and i'm like this is so
easily fixable and then i'll fix him
have you ever fixed a man yeah i fixed a
man and then i broke up with him because
you're like boring lame yeah and then
the next girl that dated i was like you
can [ __ ] have him
i tidied him up for you you [ __ ] him
up for life though because nobody wants
to be with him it's literally like i
taught him empathy oh yeah i guess he's
he's he's unfuckable now
yeah we don't want him
yeah
so you like
so is it the it's you like
broken men
it's like a project yeah but you know
the older i get the less i'm interested
yeah the old it's like the appeal that
had when i was 19 like he just needs
someone to help him now i'm like you're
a [ __ ] loser get your [ __ ] together a
grip women are not rehabilitation
centers for men get a [ __ ] grip
you're 30. you know what i mean yeah
awful so now my tolerance is a little
lower so you so like if you who who's
your who's the guy that you would settle
down with of those five who's like
you're the guy you want the most you
want my answer for today what robert
pattinson
really that's is that the batman guy
yeah and edward from twilight because
he's
he's hot
he's just hot
if he loves the twilight movie in the
peanut gallery yeah he's hot he's funny
he's witty oh god he's everything
where's my pickle beer
damn it
yeah
is he does he give i guess he gives bad
boy energy he's a little bit of a rebel
i saw some of the oh my god that's your
front kit yeah he looks good what do you
what do you think that's her phone case
so
all right let's bring out this
disgusting beer this looks nice actually
i don't even like beer either so this
whole thing is just
i'll taste it but that's all i'm doing
thank you so let's try the yeah
which means the tears of jews
[Applause]
it's a special brew
oh god that's [ __ ] disgusting it
smells bad tastes like sausage
[Laughter]
oh yeah like a [ __ ] meat candle yeah
it's got a little smoky sausage thing
there
tastes like i just
ate
barbecue and vomited it up it does that
is exactly what it is acidic vomit
it does taste like meat though
tastes like alex jones under skid mark
something like a texas barbecue
conspiracy it is do you know what this
is it's the smell and taste of you
[ __ ] in the bathroom at a barbecue
restaurant this is the one that has like
a smoky
smokiness in it but it tastes like bread
over everything else bread yeah
like sourdough essence of bread is
lingering right here
that's awful okay
awful
it tastes like
who's like a big barbecue guy that's
like a big disgusting monster i was
thinking alex jones but like who else
tastes like
it tastes like their [ __ ] as a yeast
infection
[Laughter]
it's just [ __ ] horrible i hate it
you know it's the worst part it's
probably super expensive too
they had to import this oh it's smoke
beer dot com that's like their whole
stick gross
okay
cheers
this i might be into this one is called
it has a flamenco on it strawberry
rhubarb sour ale okay let's go for it
cheers hey to austin post
cheers
that's delightful
it's called almost like sweet eh it's
almost
that tastes like a cider that's
delicious
it's a
got a little bit of a
well once when you see that it's got
flamingos on the front how bad could it
be right that's what i'm saying you're
gonna look at this and say you're not
relaxed and having a great time
strawberry rhubarb sour ale yeah that's
not bad this is delicious
okay
here's my rating
two thumbs up
no problem there
we go the little ribbon
hard coffee well that doesn't sound that
bad though it smells delicious yeah i
got no problem yeah these are gross i'm
having a great time tbr hard coffee
sounds good to you guys i mean and
compared to alex jones festering [ __ ]
barbecue licked
licked ass
yeah
alex jones hole yeah pbr's slept on man
such a good beer
okay redneck is behind the mic
ppr is pretty good
hell i'm talking about yo when you got a
10 cent per beer budget that's a fine
alcohol bushlight pbr curse
all right [ __ ]
it's sweet here
what the [ __ ] that's iced coffee wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait what this is just a sweet it's
sweet really it's an iced coffee with
alcohol it's just a hard coffee so we
thought it was going to be alcoholics we
thought it was going to be beer yo you
crack this thing first in the morning
your life is [ __ ]
because who the [ __ ] else is drinking
this that's a really good point
this is for
literally whoever made this needs help
this is for alcoholics yeah it really is
you're an alcoholic needs to get your
day going
whoever made this needs to go to [ __ ]
jail dude because it's delicious i love
it yeah this is great i actually i
wasn't planning on drinking but i think
i'm going to drink this cheers let's go
too let's get after it you uh do you
like sweet coffee you sweet coffee guy i
don't i'm i'm calorie conscious
laughs as they say that you know i go i
go uh no sugar in the coffee but extra
pepperoni on the
[ __ ] can you [ __ ] on the pizza
in fact i'm ready to get a pizza
[ __ ] my whole life but no cut no no uh
sugar in the coffee please
do you know what i'm saying like
there's some areas of my life where i'm
like super conscious about calories and
it all balances out at the end
no it doesn't well
do i need to put my stomach on the table
again
donald trump once famously said have you
ever seen a skinny person drinking a
diet coke
and i feel like
that's us yeah that's us cheers do we
have more of these
maybe let's
let's finish that one he said let's pump
the brakes
that's a yes oh boy
i saw the whole pack in there
they're all in
there you know that's that is um it's an
espresso martini but with beer how many
calories in this thing man enough
because like that's just what you got
here is a beer and they're like here's
what we're gonna do with this beer we're
gonna dump a shitload of treasures
we're going to make it [ __ ] delicious
all right cheers wait so you're not a
you don't like sweet coffee
i do is my point okay but i don't i try
not to drink it right
i um there was a trend going around on
tick tock where people were just
loving caramel macchiatos from starbucks
like an iced caramel macchiato and i've
always been like the same i go into
starbucks and i'm like i'm going to be
healthy
iced latte please but it's like
when you get it stripped back you think
it's less fat but
it was people making them at home you're
like buying the caramel sugar and buying
the starbucks sells the actual [ __ ] they
use and you put it in the iced coffee
and i got into a kick for like a week i
ordered one every day and it was so much
like i mean straight to the toilet it
was like for real pvc pipe from my
google
it was like it went straight it was like
i was pouring it down into my hole and
um it was delicious
yeah i mean those starbucks drinks have
like five or six hundred calories bro
insane it's gnarly worth it delicious i
mean they are great man
i like the uh i like those fraps you do
when i want to [ __ ] around at starbucks
i'll get a frappuccino milkshake yeah
all right
i mean coffee milkshake that's the only
difference between what i order and you
is that you i'm sophisticated yeah you
go you go oh i'll take the 1 000 calorie
drink but it's got a fancy italian name
so it's all good i i order it like this
and you go and you're like can i have a
coffee milkshake can i get a [ __ ]
coffee milkshake with
with [ __ ] sweet cream on the top
you're doing the same thing you're just
like i'll take a
crappy frappuccino
and grab
a crap a frappuccino with caramel and
you go that's cool
it's the same [ __ ] bro
can i get a [ __ ] can you just [ __ ] in
my mouth it'll be faster
can you just whoever's got covet back
there can you just [ __ ] in a cup and
serve it to me
that's basically healthier than whatever
they're giving you to drink
like i know pizza is not healthy but
damn whatever they do back there
no
i'm crying dude our life expectancy in
america goes down every year oh i'm
telling you
every time they see me park in the
chick-fil-a drive-through shave three
years off of my life oh bro that shit's
so good though chick-fil-a is so
delicious what's your favorite thing to
eat right now
right now
well
i would say mushrooms but i tried to
make a dust mushroom no i tried to make
them for myself just yesterday i just
had to freak out did you hear that no i
got dubbed
oh yeah
what are we doing
mushrooms mushrooms yeah i tried to make
mushrooms in the oven yesterday and i
did it in the oven why would you do that
because i don't know what i'm doing oh
you don't i'm just a little girl
i need help this little girl needs help
i'm not funny and i need help i'm not
smart i'm not funny and i just need help
that's the name of my autobiography
do you want to well the secret to
cooking a mushroom is that there's a lot
of moisture in them so i robbed it of
the moisture no you want to cook all the
moisture out no uh yes
well i did and it was i gagged
i said i don't know
mushroom and i put it in my mouth and i
said
yeah if you don't i feel like mushrooms
can get go really bad it was bad the the
way i like to cook it is you gotta when
you throw them in a pan and cook them
down they shrink like
90 yeah you cook you you cook them down
throw in a little butter olive oil then
you can't go wrong
but that sounds delicious yeah i don't
know what [ __ ] i did i made [ __ ] on a
pan nice and i said sarah do you want
any she was like i'm good i was like
damn so tell me about the recipe
i just did a portobello mushroom head
hollowed it out cleaned it put
cheese and um
jalapenos in it that sounds great
it wasn't no
it wasn't
so late so right now because i'm a fat
[ __ ] monster there's literally a
shame to my body and hate myself
um
you know every night is i think about
how much i hate myself because i'm so
[ __ ] fat and i have no self-control
so right now i'm i'm doing a vegetarian
diet
and i'm working on cooking all my own
meals okay so for example last night i
made a
quiche
and french fries sounds good homemade
french fries and quiche
so i took an air fryer
no i don't do i don't [ __ ] around there
it's so small i got a family to feed
damn true family of you
oh they yeah exactly
and so i took i chopped up a bunch of
spinach
you know cooked it down got the moisture
out put it with the egg
[ __ ] load of cheese bro but it's you
know that might be where you're running
into some trouble
you think so yeah
you're like i had three pieces of
spinach and a whole block of cheese and
i'm not losing weight yeah and a
frappuccino washed it down what happened
super they're like you know what what's
what start do you when you order
starbucks do you tell them the size that
they want or do you just say i want a
large
no i use the lingo see i can't because
i'm a civilized adult
and that's how you and i are different i
can't do it i can't i can't say grande
no i can't learn the sizes i don't know
what they want yeah you can yeah you
can't you're just what's this small
uh tall that doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense it's a tall a tall is a large size
tall
what's a medium grande grande means huge
no vinty means huge grande means big
grande means
it literally means big doesn't it
just a medium please
and then and then large is what
venti which means what large and what
does grande mean large okay so what the
[ __ ] am i supposed to do
because i'm not italian but you speak
spanish right i do see spanish so what's
the difference well the difference is
they don't [ __ ] use that in spanish
okay then what and then what's extra
large i don't know they have an extra
life
curse on your family
it means they had to make another size
for the big fat americans they're like
you got super large what's bigger than
that so trente means 30.
that's how many years that's how long
you're gonna live if you order that [ __ ]
how many years
no look up in italian what does venti
mean what does vintay mean in italian
guys i think it means 20. i think it
it's true they just give numbers like we
ran out of sizes you fat
what does grande mean in italian large
and what does vente mean 20. and what is
trente or whatever what does tall mean
oh wait what is this why they do that i
bet there's a logic behind it there's a
reasoning
also why the starbucks is not italian
i'm just now realizing well because that
well they they um culturally
appropriated cappuccinos from italy
but starbucks isn't known for their
cappuccinos
i guess a lot of coffee espresso and all
that's italian right yeah it's true
it's italia phobia at the end of the day
it is it's cultural appropriation of
italian x people
italian eggs italian we do
the italia x voices do matter they will
be heard i wanted to learn italian for a
bit
because they're so it's so similar to
spanish same thing
like just a little guy
put a little godfather on it yeah
speaking spanish like robert de niro he
is a
muy bien
that's good how many times i got to tell
you what the [ __ ] is a tall me and it's
a grande it's a vente that makes no
sense
walk into a starbucks
i ordered
yeah i don't know i don't i can't do it
i just say large and they know what i
mean right they know what you mean yeah
they say look at this guy
sometimes they go vente i don't
did i stutter i said large yeah i
appreciate you rebelling against the
system thank you but i am an ally to
italian people is really what i want to
communicate and you're not
you like duncan
i like duncan i think duncan's better
than starbucks but that's like a east
coast thing you can't really compete out
here in the west can you duncan's here
people are just anal about starbucks out
here
well you can go to like a starbucks
drive-through pretty much
anywhere
in la there's lots of them duncan's
where is there even a dunkin donuts
one in l.a there's duncan's yeah there's
yeah
downtown
yeah there is that's common
valley too you want some duncan
america runs on dunkin yeah let's get
some duncan let's get some duncan what
does that mean you want to get order
coffee
do you want donuts yeah that sounds good
you want to get pizza right now did you
say pizza
are you hungry brittany
yeah what do you want to eat it sounds
kind of good what what do you like on
your pie
someone to [ __ ] on it you want someone
to have covered to take a [ __ ] on it
what do you think of um the h3 special
yeah hey is i think she's special
britney what do you think of um jalapeno
pineapple and black olive pizza that's
my pizza and everyone makes fun of me
i'm not a black olive fan but i do like
i love a hawaiian pizza and i like spicy
okay first of all we're ordering pizza
okay second of all we're gonna test the
curse here today well we're drunk so we
do need pizza let's go
yo i want so i want whoever has the most
covered um basically uh most active kova
to take a steamer right on the middle of
the pie okay i know just the place i'll
put that in the notes
oh damn you're le you blasted a luke
from that one
yeah if you could get that on the pie
so what what's your dream pie
a pizza
yeah
yes pizza we're not ordering from baskin
robbins
you know
yeah sam we want we definitely want
pizza i uh
i do love a chicken barbecue pizza okay
that's a fan that's actually a favorite
around here yeah because you guys are
warm-blooded americans okay
this is
america this is america and i do still
want a pickle beer
yeah we need if we can postmate some
pickle juice that is awesome
yeah that's the worst thing ever
one of you guys should actually try this
it's [ __ ] yeah i i'm curious yeah
it's yeah i mean i don't know smell it
if you're into smoky flavors then then
you'll like it but if you're into a
brisket sandwich
it's a meal replacement
well you know some people like that what
they call is um
what do they call it there's like a
liquid that is like small liquid smoke
liquids you got it
tips i find that [ __ ] so repulsive well
one drop of it'll kill you oh really
instant death yeah like this post for
instant death
people are saying you should get pesto
on the pizza yeah
i was super sick lately
and i went to the hospital and took a
stool sample and my [ __ ] looked like
fresh pesto and i'd never seen anything
like it in fact i'll show you a photo if
you want
you know you don't have to
[Laughter]
well anyway i was showing all the guys
the photo and now everyone's saying the
masculine urge to show other men your
[ __ ] well this wasn't like a norm like
hey look at my giant it was like
medically can someone please look at
this yes
can you can you look at it
i think you'll be interested
can you please look at this it's lime
green
it is it looks neon people describe the
color as neon what did you eat
nothing i had been puking and [ __ ]
for days it was literally just bile what
in poop makes it green
that's like the top googled question and
we still don't know the answer
why is my poop green
i think people know the answer then what
is it why is my poop green they be like
oh you know the answer let's see food
may be moving through the large
intestine too quickly such as diarrhea
as a result oh it's stomach bile doesn't
have time to break down
also leafy greens
can do it
so you're pooping out stomach bile
that's must have been what it was
pull it up dan
but i do want the answer to the question
let's just bile i do want to get to the
end of this scientific hypothesis
the chlorophyll and plants produces the
green color usually yeah
i was eating grass
slightly with a dog
my stomach so i went out and was feeding
on the yard was chewing on lawn also
some frosting will do that too change
the color
what do you mean by that oh like colored
frosting yeah food coloring yeah yeah
yeah oh i was eating food coloring right
before that too drinking food coloring
like water
a shot doctor
shit's like purple we have never seen
this before what were you eating purple
and glittery god well i was drinking
purple
food dye
but other than that i can't think of
anything yeah all right so let's get a
pineapple
uh what kind of vegetarian pizza do you
like dan oh anything let's do mushroom
she's into mushrooms right now mushrooms
love mushrooms
let's go
mushroom by the way this is good
i'm into it you do you like it i don't
like it
so get me the pineapple and the [ __ ]
i think you're a sicko that's okay that
might you might be right
yeah he's [ __ ] up
he vaped for like 20 years so it brings
him back it reminds me of my smoking
days exactly yeah
is that what it's like cigarette butts
in my mouth you've got a puff but it's
just liquid smoke in it
yo [ __ ] retin link they didn't give you
alcohol and order your ass pizza
red and link i said the f word and they
they had to like they backed it up
squares
i said the f-word they took me out back
and beat me oh they [ __ ] you up yeah
but you liked it yeah i love red link
they're so nice no they're they're um
i get it dude being a
when you do too being a youtuber like
being silenced were you silent or silent
wait what do you mean by that just being
like demonetized or having things
you know like you need to take that out
they're just so hyper sensitive to it
that they try to keep it as family
friendly as possible and i respect it i
respect it basically
i feel like we've learned the ropes a
little bit here we don't get demonetized
that much anymore and
uh we we're very vulgar but those guys i
think they just they live that life
they're that family friendly guy they
like they are they are but they've got a
they got a raunchy side they did um when
i was there he just showed me his dick
and i was like bro i know right i was
like first of all nice hog second of all
not appropriate vip treatment that you
did yeah
sadly they both came in my green room
and they both pulled out their dick at
the same time said no one's ever gonna
believe you oh
and i was like this is so inappropriate
and i left and i've tried to tell and
you're trying to tell your story nobody
believes me
it's [ __ ] up
they're trying to silence you
yeah yeah
i love them i um
i think that they uh in seriousness i
think that they
created a career
path for a lot of people like really
made the internet oh yeah the format
right they've done a daily
music touring
youtube movies i mean it's wild they're
talented they really are and sweet
they're they're rare they're family man
they're good men they are got wives
they're not like toxic masculine [ __ ]
you know
love them who do you hate on the
internet
do you go there or no because i don't go
there i'm open about people i hate on
the internet and i i love that for you
yeah
i'm an allied and not even one you're
not even gonna name one person there's
gotta be one person you you're willing
to admit you hate
drumroll
no i'm not gonna say anybody oh you're
so nice
think a hate is a strong word as well
i don't i i will say i don't respect
okay
okay let's go there um a lot of the
traditional tick tock [ __ ] boys who have
made millions
of dollars from just being hot
like i know that that career has an
expiration date and that gives me some
peace of mind you know there you can't
be doing that [ __ ] when you're 35 no one
cares right so i that gives me a little
piece of mind but it's also like
that whole culture just is so insane to
me i love that kind of content where
it's like
like and that's the video yeah that's it
oh how about when there's three of them
and then the next one is crazy yeah
that's insane but it's also kind of dope
isn't it
it's just because it's like such an
oddity you can't believe it exists that
that trend that went around with that
song where they just did this
remember that
millions and billions of views
i don't get it
women do the same thing just to be just
to be fair yeah but there's a long
history of objectification there where
they've been told that they're objects
these himbos i don't have respect for
that
y'all are trying to capitalize on my
culture okay that's that's women called
we invented that [ __ ] we invented thirst
traps that's true
yeah i have no respect for those
creators
but a lot of them are kind of bad people
too it seems like very much yeah
oh it's it's shocking too i i've gotten
myself another one
i do come on guys bring out the coffee
uh degenerate start shaking in a second
yeah
eating my pizza
my shit's falling off of it um
there were i've got myself into trouble
before saying like i love this person
and then they get canceled that happens
to me every time i like anyone that's
what i'm saying is like i don't like to
give shout outs to people anymore
because i like them privately and then
when they do some [ __ ] up [ __ ] i'm
like thanks bro
thank you my darling i love him
he's a good guy
he's jack too he has a six-pack he's
been training
[Music]
i do too
i
he's going he's doing one of these
youtube boxing things no you're not yeah
i am who are you boxing a very big dude
this guy hodar
huh yeah
i swear that's his name what's his name
honda
yeah he's almost as big as hodor though
follow up his photo so brittany can
wish abe uh
uh uh well wishes in the afterlife
yeah so um
the f the tick tock [ __ ] boys
this is the guy he's fighting oh swear
to god you're gonna die yeah
he's kind of hot
yeah he is no i mean look at the veins
bro i love a beard
there you go
he's a really nice guy though can you
ask him if he's interested in me and if
the answer is if the answer is no don't
tell me yeah
like we're waiting for a response
before the match begins when you guys
are touching gloves yeah
just droppers i've got this friend all
right
he's a really good guy he seems like
super nice if you're into that
nice guys super nice guy i'm into that
well you still date him if he kills me
yeah i mean he's even hotter he's [ __ ]
up he's got damage now yeah that's true
he's got murder on his hands
poor poor guy
poor guy
yeah but that's coming up i'm actually
really excited ab as much as we goof on
him and say he's going to die he's been
training hard i think this he's going to
give this guy a run for his money he's
going to win
i think he's got a shot
yeah yeah for sure
[ __ ] that guy nah he's really nice hold
on [ __ ] him he's gonna be over your
corpse going ho door
hold the door
i loved him i was a game of thrones
adult i read all the books you read the
books [ __ ] read the books so let's
talk about the ending it was just
awful
it was an abomination i mean it was
there's never been such a crime
committed in in in cinematic history it
was disrespectful to the series i would
say it ruined creator it did i would
have gone back and watched that show so
many times by now if the last season
didn't exist knowing the last season is
there i don't go back and watch it yeah
and do we know the reason i know that
they were they had just signed on to do
another project so they were kind of
trying to wrap it up that is the reason
yeah and guess what happened the last
season was so bad they lost that gig
they got hired to make a star wars film
that's right because they were such
hot shots yes and you know the real
reason that show was good is because the
source material was amazing george rr
martin was working with them like if you
watch the first season the pacing and
the character development is [ __ ]
interesting off the main character on
the first episode i watched it with my
mom first season yeah it was the first
episode wait ed didn't die the first
episode ned died the first episode i'm
like oh it's at the end of the first
season oh yeah yeah gaslighting you know
for fun
i was like i'm pretty sure like not read
the books
no um i watched that with my mom and i
remember incredible we finished the
first up the first season and i was like
what
they're just laughing because we're
loving what you said
for reading the books oh yeah look we're
funny and people just laugh and we don't
even know why this is like joke that's
what i'm saying
is it a burden being a funny is so funny
can i okay this is a very niche thing
there was this episode of fairly odd
parents
or timmy turner got a wish and it was to
be funny to have everyone around him
always laugh at what he says
that's a monkey paw wish and i literally
and i think in the back of my head
sometimes i'm like you know you're
making people laugh you're like this is
such a good feeling like being able to
make people
joyous
and i think about that episode a lot
because he would be having like a
serious problem and he'd be like guys i
really don't want to do and they'd be
like
and i'm like that's a nightmare
for me so
yes
but
more so than like making people laugh i
want to be
i value the other side of it too do you
have trouble
getting through when you have a serious
problem because people think of you as
the funny person you're able to switch
over well that took a while on you're
talking about on the internet
sure
on the internet people are whenever i
show genuine emotion they're like
sorry but i can't take you seriously
because it's like they know me as a
jokester just a goofball so when i'm
like hey guys
don't say that i have a balding hairline
that really hurts my feelings because
i'm already self-conscious about it
things like that where i'm like don't
comment on my body don't comment on my
weight don't comment on it like my nose
shape like thing like things like that
where sarah and i talk with us all the
time i have insecurities now that i
never had pre-internet because now
people are like she's so brave for
posting her insert body part here and
i'm like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah me too
i mean it's wild and so i i try to draw
clear
uh boundaries which are following do
they respect that though or does it
matter it does the majority does because
it's the girls gays and the it's nice to
have the girls gays in the days they
really understand if i'm like y'all
please don't comment on my body like it
kind of triggers me they're like you
heard her don't comment and they'll
bully people that do they're like we
will [ __ ] hunt you down i'm serious
broski nation rise
that's nice because like i am i've
always been a fairly confident person
but now i have like such deep
insecurities about my tiny hands
that i didn't realize my hands were tiny
i don't think you have tiny hands oh
they're tiny don't [ __ ] don't even
try to blow smoke up my ass you got the
littlest hands i've ever seen yeah no
they're tiny and it doesn't make sense
like i'm bigger i'm tall i'm like the
tallest person in my family
small people
okay
my brother's shorter but i got the small
i got these [ __ ] small hands
like when i was in high school playing
water polo i was trying to be an athlete
i couldn't grip the ball everyone's out
here like
i got a i literally had to hold it like
that
and you know i feel like i'm pretty
athletic when i'm in shape and stuff but
i have tiny hands
and have you let that get you down in
life
[Music]
well it didn't ever i never even thought
about until all these [ __ ] i'm
saying man it's like
at least you were grown by the time you
weren't 15 years i was already married
right people
being like god damn you got some tiny
ass hands sometime [ __ ]
said they do it when you're a kid oh
high five baby hands high five where's
your hand baby
yeah exactly
yeah
but i always try to wear my insecurities
uh on my sleeve so that
you make it part of your act yeah i do
the same thing yeah i embraced having a
big ass forehead well let's see it
pretty big i mean what was that because
just yeah and i like the curtain reveal
like all right trigger warning forehead
yeah i got bangs for a reason because
people were like what's going on up
there megamind people do that a lot i've
noticed beforehead people get a lot of
griff on the uh you know who's got a big
forehead who's that deutsche cat rihanna
oh yeah she got a big ass forehead don't
you know big four heads and that's
beautiful they're both beautiful i never
thought about i don't think about the
forehead thing right you and i didn't
either before people were like god damn
[ __ ]
you're hard to look at you got a big
forehead
come on well you know i'll be honest i
haven't eaten all day
i'm feeling it oh yeah and i'm still on
my first one i don't drink ever ever
pretty much never i love drinking
i think i'm just too like i'm i'm 36 i'm
pretty [ __ ] old but you're in your
mid-20s i'm 24. i got kids i got to put
a kid to bed i got to make dinner but
you don't go to sleep and be like i need
a beer
it's just not my blood you know my no
one in my family drinks
it's just not something my
i didn't grow up around alcohol my
parents never drank in front of me so
you unwind with a with a beer or a no i
don't unwind
oh yeah that's pretty i'm wound pretty
yeah
i'm right that's the misnomer but you
end your evening with the drink
um i like to party
and black out on five white cloth
seltzers but you're young when i was
your age i was doing that too
yeah la
man this is something else they don't
talk about la culture is so
about
being drunk
and i had no idea you know like oh yeah
come to my house let's hang out oh let's
do this let's film oh we're drinking all
during that
and especially like l.a parties of
course you're drinking but i never
realized every event is centered around
alcohol which is fun until it's like
i've been drunk for three days i don't
want to keep like it's a bender at that
point and it gets dangerous so
definitely well i don't really go out
because
it's hard when you're like sober guy and
people around you are doing drugs
absolutely
it's just that the vibe is not the same
yeah there's no appeal and you lose
friendships that way too when it's like
i really don't want to associate because
that's all y'all are doing we can't have
a normal conversation because you're
just you can't go
you can't easily just go be with them
when they're trashed you're right the
vibe is not there that [ __ ] is mad
annoying when you're the only sober one
yeah well cheers let's get drunk [ __ ]
that question
i'm feeling it cheers let's get some pot
did you order pizza sam
yep eta
[Music]
25 30 minutes well as someone who loves
malone this is basically what we would
do
when he was here to see him do you see
him a lot no
we're estranged
no you're not we are you stop talking
yep why
i think he loved the guy
great guy
he's got a fast life
he's much younger than me i mean he's
around your age so i'm like i have kids
and [ __ ] you know and responsibilities
and stuff and um
he moved to like utah or something again
which i get you know it's fine like i
i'm here
because my wife has a clothing company
we have this entertainment industry my
family's here everything makes sense
yeah it makes it here i like i actually
like la though i mean i like being here
and that's interesting because you're
from
so
yeah
i i genuinely like being here i feel
like people exaggerate the
problems with la where if people go like
everyone here is fake and just trying to
social climb it's like well that's who
you're hanging out with bro right
unfortunately also the platforms on
which we exist everyone's trying to
social climb off each other yeah gross
if you you are surrounding yourself i
mean there's so many different
communities and things such a huge city
you can find uh i agree pretty much
anything here and it's also like
if you're not entertaining enough by
yourself
you need to social climb off of others
maybe you shouldn't be doing this job
i think there's
there there
there's truth to that i mean you're
you're not gonna
find success through other people
you're probably just a talentless
[ __ ] loser to begin with that's it
i don't respect you
actually i hate you yeah
i hate all of y'all everyone what's
y'all have a chat going
i'm not chatting with anyone i was just
clicking highlighting stuff oh no
there's a ch the chat they chat yeah
that's what i'm saying what are you guys
chatting about girls we're over here
just talking [ __ ]
you're not talking about her forehead
are you no
no though mostly about ethan the
followers
oh we have a life oh yes we do have a
life yes i'm talking about
they love you yeah they love you they
love you they've been asking for you to
come on for a while
here you want to read the live chat i
kind of do here let's pull it up love
you she's the best hi brittany god i
love i love you she's forehead forehead
tiny forehead queen forehead yes
tiniest forehead you've ever seen tiny
forehead queen
[Laughter]
keep it coming see my fans know how to
flat they say have massive hands now
they say that about me they go this
motherf they start all the fan art now
has me with massive hands they always
draw them with huge hands now yeah yeah
[ __ ] wreck it right hey can i get a
glass with some ice please
will you be able to hold it what is this
what where are you going
i'll get right on this sir what then why
i just said why are you yelling i was
just kidding making a joke cause being a
diva okay
wait so you don't you don't talk to
posting yeah so um
broski nation uh they're saying
be in for life
four four hit five head nah that's not
nice come on guys
how about a three head
i'll take that i'll take a three head
you're so small you don't even have one
oh my god did you have a birth defect
you're tired so small my hairline starts
right here oh my god
hairy ass forehead
um
oh my god do you have a birth defect or
something your forehead is so small
your hairline is like right on your
eyebrows thank you honestly how many
chromosomes do you have a lot
too many
a lot
too many to count
yeah so i mean love the guy i have
nothing bad to say i think his life is
just fast he moved out of l.a
he's thank you lina
hey don't make me ask this time please
just kidding
yeah i want to see the color of it does
it look like a starbucks iced coffee i
think i'd like to um dilute it a little
bit
yeah this is there's alcohol in this
i'm feeling tipsy you want another one
this is my second one do you want
another one no i'm all right i would
like some ice though too can we get some
eyes yes sir coming right up sir you
have to yell at them if you want
anything
can you do it you don't finish your
[ __ ] story okay
so um
basically there's nothing to it really
he just you know he moved away
and um we kind of just stopped talking
and i think i got a new phone and he got
a new phone and maybe i don't know
he's just and like you know he's become
progressively more famous like every day
and more reclusive more reclusive maybe
and uh he has like bigger and more
famous friends and
he's just um
you know he was rocking some teddy fresh
in a recent video though he was so
that's so nice that's so nice i don't
think there's any bad blood there
no no no i don't think there's bad blood
i like i love post he's just he's a
total sweetheart i could never say
anything bad about him
he had nice things to say about you on
stevo's podcast he said he missed you oh
that's nice yeah so but like i mean i'm
just being real i haven't talked to him
in a minute
it's fair yeah
he's a busy bee a busy baby
oh mama mia i love him he's one of those
people that's like he's so nice though
that's the thing is he's nice he's real
i know he's rich as [ __ ] but like he's
now he's gotta be mega rich he's so
down-to-earth though and i he's one of
those people how i feel about doji cat
where it's like we would just be i love
doji cat we would be
like just one of those people that you
want to think about about me when you
used to search yeah yeah
yeah
and i said how's it going it's going
good yeah hey one of these okay good
but um like i don't know you saw that
clip of him like that was going viral of
him saying hi to a fan
you know
did you see that can you guys pull that
up it was a young fan's birthday and he
was like super sweet
and it was going viral but he's always
liked that when we were out in public
always time for the just so sweet and
nice and just very sweet sweet guy you
know
so i think i'm gonna pump the brakes on
this because i'm having some heart
palpitations oh my god
do we have the defibrillators you guys
in case we need them
the defragulators
you want something else you you got the
water i'm good okay
so let's see you following the fresh and
fit guys surely you hate them fresh and
fit
they're like the alpha male do you
following the whole alcohol
what is that
really what is that like red pill stuff
no you don't i know like um uh
nicki rockstar
can you guys pull up some red pill
premium
this recent one of the guy uh
saying
um like dick pills right cooking is for
poor people and only women should cook
okay that's good you uh here let me give
you a point here i got it right here
that's a good point i i'm really into
the the so there's this pickup pickup uh
artists
they're and they say red pill which
actually it's funny their whole ideology
comes from a matrix meme the blue or red
pillow yeah so red people took both
pills end up in roku city
you seen that what's roku city on roku
tvs it's the screen style
i know roku city that's like both pills
end up in ropes that's awesome
yo i've watched that roku screensaver
for a long time it's good it's not bad
the spaceship one fantastic we just fall
asleep to it i go how those windows line
up every time i know it's so satisfying
how do i [ __ ] do that
yeah when it would like finally go to
the corner it was like yeah i didn't
know anyone used roku i was like this is
the most off-brand [ __ ] no roku slay
i'm a roku adult okay good for you whoa
roku city is a vibe the city's like look
at this yeah gorgeous
it just scrolls endlessly and they'll
put movie promos actually on them
wait i don't remember the robots in
godzilla and [ __ ] maybe i have an old
version can you pull up the spaceship
roku
can you please play some lo-fi
yeah some low-fi hip-hop and just let
and let's just be quiet
yeah the girl with the cat
right exactly yeah yeah exactly
but anyway there's this ideology that
like
they've taken the red pill and they
become aware
that
you know
women are basically all succubus who
want money they use
yeah it's in south culture yeah so i
agree i'm very into that
yeah i mean i'm very into you know
following there right no you know what
i'm talking about uh nikki rockstar
that's his name
yeah yeah this is the spaceship one
and they have big alien monsters that
will attack the ship like how the robots
were attacking the city
can we play it
oh this is a screenshot oh
i never saw this one huh
so here's one that came up recently i'll
just show it to you
uh this this guy we've learned so much
about this guy i saw this and i was like
man this guy's [ __ ] nuts
he was date you know who jordan peterson
is no
oh [ __ ] well people watching though
michaela peterson his daughter dated
this guy
apparently she actually
michaela peterson this is for people
watching
was married she has a she has a child
and she [ __ ] left her family for this
guy
this red pill guy yeah watch you're
upset
you turn it up yeah can we come and
crank it please guys i'm gonna miss a
word bro
and you're gonna spend
time
time is what
money money time is money always be
closing
hey buy low sell high
oh
is that it buy low sell high oh
it's called red pill credentials mental
behavior yeah
yeah
hell yeah bro damn why is he so [ __ ]
aggressive
because he's alpha time time
daddy
play it i want to hear i want to hear
what the man has to say
you're going to spend time
preparing food
now actually think about this for a
second
if you're broke if you're not a
millionaire
the last thing you should be doing with
your time is cooking
i can't think of a lower roi activity
than walking to the fridge
getting out some ingredients oh an onion
yummy
oh an onion
what kind of [ __ ] loser cuts an onion
shame on you
oh look at me i'm an idiot what the
onions
oh you probably don't [ __ ] low roi yo
what's the return on that onion time
[ __ ]
how long does it take to chop an onion
by the way
a minute and a half yeah
you could have been earning during that
minute exactly what i'm saying
how much could you earned in that minute
and a half
at least a couple cents get those meat
candles out boys
and start
ooh earning onion and some lettuce
well now losers and onion and lettuce
cut my onion
dude you're [ __ ]
[Music]
you're [ __ ] weirdo
you can order you can get rotisserie
chicken for five bucks boom
chicken back eat back back to work
i love that
okay now i gotta go earn what are you
darning
okay now we gotta go scam people on the
internet again
holy [ __ ] okay oh our e now i gotta go
get some nfts and crypto right right
right him just
sucking on a rotisserie
screenshotting other people's nf
[Music]
so busy he's stupid bones he's got a
corner full of bones
if you're not sucking rotisserie chicken
like a goger you are wasting time my
friends
you could [ __ ] do a million things
you can go for a run you can get in
shape the time you spent cooking if you
dedicated to kickboxing you could have
got paid for
or piano you could [ __ ] be a
traveling piano man who's paying me to
play piano that's not easy gig no it's
not our kickboxer you think kickboxing
will make money in this economy think
again you [ __ ] weirdo how are you
gonna kickbox also how are you gonna
kickbox if you ain't eating onions and
[ __ ] you gotta eat healthy just running
on pure meat yeah
this man's this man's theory of life is
five dollar rotisserie chicken forever
literally yeah
i'm so happy for him yeah he figured it
out it made him go bald but whatever
works there he says there's no worse roi
than cooking
what about sleep
solid point that's a waste of [ __ ]
time about the point well you know what
with that like grind culture they're
like i go to sleep rise and grind yeah i
wake up at 3 30 a.m i run 10 [ __ ]
miles
what's a bad roi i love this cooking
maybe [ __ ] maybe there's their way
to toilet time for sure is there a way
to streamline [ __ ] maybe get a
colostomy bag
i mean it's fast
you get a cat that you don't have to
stop and go to the bathroom dude a
catheter you didn't wheel in your piss
bag
i mean
right you gotta save time god damn it i
got a meeting with richard
what are you doing
get a [ __ ] catheter that is broke
[ __ ] behavior wheel in your piss bag
and take the call
like get a grip pig is for rich people
and winners
i wear a diaper [ __ ]
i [ __ ] myself because i don't have time
i don't have enough hours in the day all
you little weirdos go to the bathroom
during a bishop
it's for rich winners it's stealing from
company time you know what respect your
boss you know what i used to work um at
an insurance brokerage
and they used to i mean down to the
minute monitor what we were doing we had
a big board kind of like these screens
that had everyone every employee's name
and you had to log what you were doing
at that moment oh my god so you had to
be like i'm either on an inbound phone
call an outbound phone call i'm working
on you know emails i'm on break or i'm
on lunch bathroom bathroom
no it just said like break
and so if you take like a long steamer
is it awkward well here's let me finish
the story because that's exactly where
i'm going
is um legally you have to take two
15-minute breaks a day because if you
work for eight hours nine hours straight
you know they could sue you
um so
for lunch we would get an hour well at
the end of my lunch because i have i
don't know ibs
when i eat it goes straight through me
and so i go to the bathroom at the end
of my lunch break well i like to spend
10 20 30 minutes in the bathroom that's
my me time
i would have to log i'm on lunch she'd
be like oh britney's been on lunch for
an hour and 20 minutes where is she they
would go into the bathroom no way look
for me they'd look for your feet knock
on the door
britney
you were off of lunch 20 minutes ago you
need to wrap it up right i'm not kidding
they would be like you need to pinch it
off yo
[Music]
yo you need to retract that [ __ ] in you
and work on that later you need to
there's calls you need to be taken
because we worked at a call center
that is one of the most humiliating
things that's ever happened oh my god i
would do it on purpose too i'd be like
50-minute break [ __ ] you guys i'm taking
45 minutes they'd be like they brought
me into the hr people that fired you no
this was the i quit because i was like
clinically depressed like it was awful
um it was just that micromanaging and i
still keep that with me i feel like when
i'm being unproductive
it's those managers in the back of my
mind like you need to be working are you
really [ __ ] right now literally
you're [ __ ] you've been in here for 40
minutes
like that's my means i'm having fun in
here man you know i had a similar
problem i mean people were pretty fair
about it and when i was we lived in
israel i was working a
uh desk job and i used to take really
long shits and miss like meetings and
[ __ ] yeah and they'd be like he's in the
bathroom yeah i don't [ __ ] i don't spend
as much time in the in the bathroom as i
did there's a dad really you don't hide
in the bathroom as a dad
i would
dude when i'm in the bathroom [ __ ]
theodore's literally outside pounding
going daddy let me in he wants to come
in there when i'm [ __ ] he wants to
sit with you and he goes i he demands
privacy when he shits now he goes i need
private time i say i need private time
yeah daddy's private time yeah it's
daddy's private time
i get it but um
that's humiliating america is fine we're
our cultures fine
it literally that was my first taste of
it was being like you are a warm that's
gonna be illegal by the way it is yeah
but i mean who cares right yeah you're a
warm body filling this chair and i quit
and i pro i bet they hired someone
within three days well the call center
anyone can answer calls like a monkey
the good thing these days is that
there's been so many resignations that
it's there's finally workers have some
uh negotiating there because people
can't hire enough people these days and
they don't pay him enough the conditions
are horrible and people are saying [ __ ]
you that was the thing i had a full
college degree that i just paid eighty
thousand dollars for and i was making 15
bucks an hour
i was making 38 39 000 a year to not
even be able to take a [ __ ] in peace
to be accused of that's the thing is
like uh they were accusing me of
stealing from company time stealing
money stealing resources on company time
shut the [ __ ] up
shut up you're an insurance company you
steal from people that's your that's you
that is you yeah they're like how can we
they're like okay yeah so this person
can never work again but uh
our data shows that he did push the gas
and he was going one mile per hour
proving it is his health condition yeah
shut the [ __ ] up oh my god insurance is
a scam
anyway this guy's awesome yeah i love
him i want to watch more of him you know
his name is cobra tate
tate first name is holbrook well i i
think his first name is andrew but he go
his his cobra has two syllables what a
waste of time oh that's so true shorten
that down [ __ ] she wasting my time with
those dudes he was on the right track
with this his name should just be
his name
we got to streamline that name cobra
yeah wasting my time talking about keep
it going i want to see what i want to
see what the good lord has to say with
the time you've wasted cotton [ __ ]
onions if you're broke there is zero
reason why you should ever prepare a
meal
if you're a multi-millionaire and you're
a boring one you're not a fun one like
me
boring ones and you have all the time in
the world because you're rich you want
to cook sure waste your time right but
if you're not a multi-millionaire your
time is extremely important as a man
that needs to be dedicated towards world
conquest
i'm going to make a video for him like
the girl did for vladimir putin
i wish he was you were his mom that's
what i'm saying like if someone would
have just hugged him as a child i don't
think he had a mom you did a good job
yeah none of this would have ever
these men they have these holes they're
so unloved
that they are constantly taking and
taking they're trying but they nothing
can fulfill them they're so unloved
they're such a huge hole they may he's a
child you can tell he's a baby yes i
mean look how he's acting and talking
he's like it's these men think that it's
them against the world
and it's not like dude [ __ ] relax
cutting [ __ ] onions relax
it takes 10 minutes to prepare a salad
the sad thing is he wants to be loved
but he is unlovable
yeah i would agree like dude
you're unlovable and this is the type of
dude on dating apps it's like no fat
chicks
just being real
just being real with you oh that reminds
me we should refresh and fits dating
you guys see that the fresh and fit his
dating profile got leaked and it's like
literally what it's so [ __ ] good yeah
one percent he says i'm in the one
percent just being real period look that
up but anyway let's watch a
gorilla brain over here
he's kind of like a primal prank like a
bad way
need money
it's like we're human beings man we're
out of the cave
look at this beautiful society we built
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay chill gorilla
roi roi oh my oh my roi abc always be
closing
[Music]
oh you're kidding you're kidding what is
this wait let's finish this okay
i'm so excited yeah this is good stuff
which can be done very cheaply and very
helpfully your rotisserie chicken in a
bag of salad for like four bucks back
done
or instruct a female to provide
sustenance bro you did not
is he serious i love when he says female
like that that's red flag number one
when a man says these females yeah like
it's a slur
instruct a female that is insane
okay why does he say it like that
cook
and get back to world conference you
have better things to do
so i'm sitting here my friend's cooking
his meal i start telling him you're
you're a jackass
his friend preparing a meal for the two
of them you're a jackass
you're literally sitting there with him
like you guys are already not doing
something
better you're just socializing with your
friends yeah
jackass no i do not want to hang out
with you bro you're a beta [ __ ] male
you're a [ __ ] dude you're a [ __ ]
you're cutting onions
what are you crying
doesn't that prove me right no that
cruising totally right
why is his head shaped like that
like i'm just saying bro
look at his forehead bro there's like a
slope there man i don't think you should
be coming out with theories when your
head shaped like that
i'm just saying
like save the theories for someone with
a normal shape
with that chrome without like a [ __ ]
early man slope on your dome
like dude you should probably just go
live in a cave somewhere with your other
neanderthal [ __ ] primates
fire scary fire make me angry
female cook me male you female hello
i can't think of anything more stupid
for a man to do
something are you broke yes do you cook
probably do you not see the problem here
that is a complete
waste of your human time
the cooking the preparation i love that
it's not a waste of time for females
though right right right right that's a
good use of time so he's there for what
a equals b equals c he's saying that
women aren't human human well no females
aren't human female cook
man
conquest no and he's so true it's like
it's true yeah is this he's spitting
facts no like you guys should listen to
him
but anyway this is the guy that that
jordan peterson's daughter michaela
ruined her through her old family away
for that is insane and i'm not speaking
at a turn right that that that's true
right evidently yeah uh i i
we saw this clip last night
and as i was doing a little digging on
like who is this guy uh i was shocked to
find out that he uh has a long history
of um
doing some
very uh unscrupulous things in no way in
eastern europe uh like what
like
being a sex trafficker and oh yeah
like child bride no no more like sex
trafficking oh yeah well he was he was
getting his girlfriends to do webcam
stuff and then taking their money yeah
like pimping out he said r-o-r that's
our
female yeah when he's talking about roi
what that is the business
vin weasel nice
that's good yeah this guy looks like
he's stuck in a transformation between
rat and human
see that's that that's what i was
catching on
um here's another one of his before we
get to fresh and fit i'm glad you're
enjoying this because this is i love
insole dudes i love super intuitive
actually seeing like how out of touch
with reality they can get it's very
interesting to me well it's scary that
people actually
are like he's right and you know what i
think that it's um
when people well the internet's very
scary too because it gives people like
this a platform and there are it gives
men that agree with him a platform as
well like he's getting all the support
that he probably needs but also it opens
him up to bullying and i really love
that that's true people get to [ __ ] on
him he has to read that [ __ ] oh yeah and
they don't like it no look at him
dude okay
okay
dude
just taken in the image of him is a lot
right now
so is this a time stamp you want me to
watch jb this specific time stamp
uh i'm sorry i didn't send this one um
oh cam sent this is this the right time
stamp cam
yes okay what do you stand for
it's short for abdullah
i love that
but it's also here why don't you go by
abe
too many apes in my hometown
so here they are by the way
is that him
he's oh yeah that's him oh no he's hot
so he actually looks better without
glasses i don't know why he wears
glasses if he had hair he'd be cute
yeah i mean if he had a normal shaped
dome he'd be hot if his head wasn't so
horribly misshapen yeah if he wasn't
from the prehistoric age he'd be hot
if his knuckles didn't drag on the
ground behind right
dude dude looks like he should be
dressed like fred flintstone
so there she is with him so he's pretty
i actually found a picture of him before
he lost his uh lost his hair let's see
it yeah here it is
holy [ __ ]
my boy
he looks great yeah you look good you
look good why is this poor neanderthal
got like acne
that's a good ques yeah i mean obviously
that's like a recreation why did they
have to do them like that why'd they go
to [ __ ]
prehistoric men can't have cysts on
their faces yeah but like they have
recreated them why they got to do them
like that yeah they said we're gonna
give him horrible scarring yeah if you
dig me up and exhume me you better give
me good skin yeah you better face tune
the [ __ ] out of me
on the left is what his skull is shaped
like
all right let's
watch a man can only cheat if he loves
someone else if i have a woman who i
truly love and i go out and [ __ ] and i
come back to her and i don't care about
her and i only love my girl that's not
cheating
what
she cooked good
she cooked good but you don't [ __ ] good
i'm speechless exercise if she even
talks to a dude is cheating because
females are emotionally invested i have
no emotional investment so no he's like
i'm not even emotionally invested in my
girlfriend to be honest exactly yeah
yeah no
oh it's fine i love that it was very
very clear any woman who's with me never
never even the only men they spoke to
besides me were my brother hai
and the guys online who were paying them
that is it they were absolutely loyal oh
yeah so he's talking that's a reference
to them yeah yeah
yeah
arabic
he grew up in the uk and
i don't know his ethnicity to be honest
qa has always been frowned upon
this guy's a this guy man so yeah that's
that is
shocking
he means every word
that's watching so how did those four
girls exit oh
see this is the people who watch him
they go yeah
this guy you know his fan the people who
watch him are one bad day away from
shooting up at school
i'm just being honest you know what i
mean
this dude looks like his mommy dressed
him for this interview
because mommy tried to wax his eyebrows
too and it didn't work looks like his
mommy molested him that's why it's the
way he is let's just be honest this is
mommy's fault
he was diddled as a boy oh yeah
oh for sure
you can tell when someone's been diddled
or if they're diddler
he could go either way yeah except just
to be with you those other girls sleep
if other people are absolutely not
that's cheating bro a woman can't do
that that's cheating it's fine if i do
i'm a man why does he pick when he has a
british accent
yeah absolutely not bro
that was interesting i noticed that yeah
he grew up in the uk but he only has a
british accent for like certain words
when he wants to yeah what the deal okay
this giant fly
all right get out there
[ __ ] do it kill it
with your hand do your other hand on it
no he's gonna shoot it come on baby
it's on my hand
hooray
it lived is that air the boy who came to
live never lived come come die
do it close your eyes you don't have to
close your eyes get closer
[Music]
okay
[Music]
no it's salt
okay that [ __ ] is dead what does salt
do
it just kills flies like bullets
here oh open your eye
[Laughter]
it's just still it's just a projectile
that's it
yeah just shoot salt a little puff of
salt what is the purpose of this to kill
flies
it's called a bug assault
it's hard yeah now it's ready
[Music]
no not hair
you got there's a safety it's a whole
thing i this stresses me out absolutely
yeah
yeah so you
think i'm gonna hurt myself
yeah so now it's ready to go
yeah it ricochets sometimes so be
careful wait you all really have a fly
problem we use we used to
i felt that you salted dan bro
it's funny when it's far away because it
it just it just
feels like a little assaulted someone i
need to pee again are you mad at me no
not at all go for
it let's check in on the chat
um what the pizza's almost here enjoy
let's do more red pill because i think
this is pretty this is hitting pretty
good eh
it's pretty good it's pretty good
not bad not bad
i don't know it's okay here let's watch
this actually i wanted to watch this
clip
i'll wait for her though can't wait for
her yeah
um and then so fresh and fit apparently
his dating profile got leaked and it's
super good
i'm surprised you guys didn't see that
it was like on a subreddit sugar daddy
website supposedly
wow
that makes sense
i like the new set looks good the
lighting looks good too well thank you
dan built that behind you himself i know
that was amazing dan built that [ __ ]
damn
the plan was to uh kind of paint it and
you know do maybe some fun like kind of
graffiti stuff on it like you know an
outdoor brick wall but uh ethan you said
you just like the brick
love the brick
i don't know if ela's down with the
brick i like the brick well i think she
just doesn't like that it
doesn't match
when i got the message what's with the
brick i was like oh i know i said i know
what that means
i like the brick
um
happy friday everybody what are you guys
doing this weekend
uh i am gonna go shopping for a suit
because i'm going to a wedding next
weekend i gotta look fly i haven't
bought a suit in like
seven years it's been a long [ __ ]
time yeah i'm about to buy a suit too
but the one i have does not fit anymore
too small yeah you're pretty skinny
still so yes but i was a lot skinnier
when i was 25 26 so
all right let's finish this and we'll do
the fresh and refreshing fit how's that
pete where's that pizza at
sam
it's going to be here at 2 45 which is
right [ __ ] now
moment where is it it's about my hand
you're about to burst through the wall
this lean back yeah
there's a tab here that clicks
that would be there on that side you got
it
yeah nice
all right let's watch some women can't
shoot why women can't cheat
people that's cheating that's absolutely
unacceptable on every level that's
unacceptable and anyone it was going to
sit here and say oh it is acceptable no
it isn't men and women are not the same
we've never been the same this new think
idea that men and women are the same is
complete garbage that's been invented
right for our longest period of human
history men had a role in women had a
role men have never been faithful
ever look at history every single king
every single sultan had more than one
king dude
sorry if you yeah you're talking about
your ass is the peasant sitting in the
[ __ ] [ __ ] sewers
yeah
your ass ain't getting that king
treatment he said every sultan shut the
[ __ ] up
yeah i mean back in the day kings used
to like [ __ ] new brides yeah that shit's
medieval bro what's his name anthony
they used to also like this guy's name
yeah no it's cobra it's cobra tate now
what's his real name yeah i believe it's
andrew tate
andrew motherfucker's name is andrew and
he's talking about sultan's
andrew yeah you know you know what else
they used to also do
they used to
uh tie people's limbs to horses and
[ __ ] draw them in quarters and rip
them apart i bet he loves that
you know what i'm saying so
i just found another fun little detail
about him
apparently he was on uh
on big brother like oh of course he was
the
british uh
big brother at one point yeah the
british version and he got kicked off
after pornographic content of him
whipping a woman was leaked
he's so scary sounds fine so scary
actually yeah it's a little scary he's
actually a sex trafficker and that's
epic no literally this dude is like a
deep rooted misogynist like scary
like violent like a violent misogynist
oh he was an mma fighter by the way oh
did he only fight women
yeah yeah
god
woman look at the history read the bible
it's all there never any point in
history was a woman with a bunch of men
and that was
accepted female cleopatra
famously f did that
so
wrong disproven
eat my shorts [ __ ]
[Music]
why you talk like this
has always been frowned upon since the
dawn of human time it's been fraud
frowned upon in fact
only a hundred years ago you couldn't
get married unless you were a virgin
that ain't true what the [ __ ] is he
saying no i know that ain't true you had
sex what book did you read can't get
married
what do you know 100 years ago you
couldn't even get married if you were
born a virgin 100 years ago in 1922 they
were asking you yeah are you a virgin
let me check here you know
yeah the end stones the insult
is incredible
oh this is just piss i love the little
beta boy it's so true
you know what he sounds like yeah boss
yeah yeah yeah tell him a hundred years
ago yeah
he's right
well you couldn't get married yeah and
you're so smart boys with these ladies
having sex yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's so true i love you so much boys
want to kiss you in the mouth yeah what
he sounds like
only thing that mattered because it
ensures paternity how else do you know
that kid is yours before a paternity
test unless she was a virgin the only
way to be sure
you understand what i'm saying so women
for the longest period of human time the
idea of a promiscuous female has been
frowned upon and shamed in half of the
world today it's still shamed so a woman
can't go around [ __ ] people and
pretend it's the same as a man running
around [ __ ] people it's absolutely
not the same
all right shut up yeah i've heard enough
so fresh and fit is kind of the same
thing
we have a podcast where real quick yeah
um the pizza is in here but something
else important is okay you want to bring
that out can i eat it yes is it edible
again yes
wait where did these come home are you
serious
wait did we really just buy these
no [ __ ] way
we just got pickled juice shot now what
is the purpose of this
for shots just for the people that love
pickle juice pickle shots are this is a
real thing pickle shots are real yeah i
never had a pickle shot
they make these
we just insta carted a jar a little jar
of pickle juice i don't know what these
are but pickle shots at the bar just a
mixed pickle of vodka or pickle with
tequila i don't think there's alcohol in
it no i don't think so this is literally
just but we have alcohol don't we dan
you said you want to pour it in your
beer
oh well
wait
yeah oh [ __ ] yeah no sorry wait there's
no like seal on it
this just open there's no seal
it's a whole like a little suspicious
there was no seal on my head asking me
like i made these well you're the pickle
keeper i don't know what the [ __ ] this
[ __ ] is i am the pickle girl wait wait
wait wait wait
did i take this off because there was no
seal on it
yours didn't have a seal
you didn't have to do this
no no
that one's been drinking out of wait why
is it not stealing my pickle [ __ ]
ian just said he sam took him off oh
she's catching me out sam
you like pickles
not that much
you're talking about the game earlier
the pickle
i like pickles but what the [ __ ] is this
it's pickle juice you were demanding
pickle juice just like 45 minutes ago i
didn't think that it actually existed
in a five-hour energy can it was like
kind of refreshing it's delicious this
with some vodka i'll take three of these
be dehydrated for the next few days
getting drunk
you want to get drunk so bad well i'm
just trying to accommodate you
when did i say i want to be a degenerate
alcoholic
i'll be all right i am going to finish
this though also i think the pizza is
here but okay bring it out
so um
is fresh and fit those um
he's another guy with a shitty hairline
yes oh yes actually yeah oh yeah he's
balding big time they always are
so he they have this podcast called
fresh and fit it's all about like incel
dumb and red pill [ __ ]
so somebody found his uh can you pull it
up danny yeah
somebody found his uh dating profile he
says about me
i'm just here to find a brunette side
chick to compliment my blonde trophy
wife that is pregnant with our mulatto
baby is that real is this real wait why
is this real
just kidding okay social media
influencer and content creator run a
popular podcast in miami i bet a vodka
soda you can't guess my ethnic
background i own a high ticket coaching
business but i'm realizing the notorious
bag song mo money mo problems is
disappointingly true i'm hoping you
don't add to that disappointment not to
sound cocky but here are my numbers only
four percent of the male population is
over six two
less than three percent of males make
over three hundred thousand a year only
five percent of men are in shape with
abs
you lucked out i have all three in one
package so yeah i'm picky for a reason
beauty in women is common but high value
men are not
be prepared to compete
this has got to be a parody this
unfortunately is very on brand for him
holy [ __ ] bring those out pizza pizza
pizza pizza
oh [ __ ] oh my god that h3 budget yeah
look at that that's yours we should swap
yeah that's fine
yeah we got that h3 budget
oh mama mia
mommy mommy i feel like i'm getting the
real oh
i will break this mic if you let me
this is the post malone experience this
is the post balloon experience the 4d
imax experience um
[Music]
yeah i'll take one
hook him up with a player welcome to the
truth everyone welcome let's go i've
been eating healthy
for like
a week
it's all over i want to try one of yours
yeah try it tell me what you think
i won't talk mad [ __ ] on it
but i like her i think um
the
high value man [ __ ] is a crazy thing to
talk about because
this is what
this is men seeing other men through the
male gaze
hmm
of like
in his mind this is what he thinks an
attractive man is is like
rich crims hemsworth ripped body gay he
literally loves yeah yeah he loves men
and i think that that's beautiful but i
think that he should
admit it you're so right
it's the male gaze no woman wants the
[ __ ] he's describing we want a man
that's respectful and nice right you ask
any woman that's the top two qualities
him
big tits fat ass i've got a huge [ __ ]
i'm rich tight [ __ ]
my [ __ ] is tight as [ __ ] and i love
sucking [ __ ]
literally that's what his profile should
be
seeking a man any man
that's so true right
that's good it's spicy
it's yeah
oh my god i'm in heaven right now
this is like the best thing ever
do we have more alpha [ __ ] we can watch
hard rock nick pull him up y'all have
seen him oh i don't know him
hard rock nick
i want to
you'll know him once you see him he's
one of those og's yeah he's an insole
guy
major major
he's got like that wild beard i think
we've talked about him before
love it
hit me with that
oh send me a link i'll open it
[Music]
what kind of pizza do you guys get
never be a beta guy never be a beta no
is that him
no no okay
never be a beta be baiting a beta is
death that's what he says play zach
never ever do it it is death
death he's right i'd rather die than be
a beta
if only you can see what this guy looks
like
by the way this is fresh and fit the guy
who wrote that dating profile
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this guy oh
[ __ ] you know what women want
hair
sorry not a shiny head
yeah he went viral on tick tock because
this woman ate him up ate his ass up
mm-hmm left that [ __ ] speechless
[ __ ] this guy
um
sorry this is the pizza getting part of
the show guys
oh this is wait is this guy an insole
hard rock nick i didn't realize
then why does he look like
he's he's a bottom
i know
what's up guys so i've seen his face but
i've never really engaged with this
content i don't know if this is a good
uh video
like do
like search hard rock nick
uh
uh
he did one of like describing his
perfect woman do hard rock night perfect
woman perfect woman guys
oh my god i need this
it's just as bad as you think it is says
stop wifing
hell yeah
my boy
dude straight up looks like
he's scary it's keem's brother dude
give giving wario vibes i know
giving
guys i need you to understand
that we gotta stop wifing
this young generation i'm talking to you
guys that are 18 to 30
don't be wi-fi
don't be wi-fi the first [ __ ] that
[ __ ] orgasms on your dick
and you know what i'm saying like
bruh i know once this guy's never made a
woman come back because it's like never
seen him never know and then it's also
expensive to date
i get it
i know why like being married there is
something to be said for it
it's basically [ __ ] in the bank it's
always there
your money's in the bank it's like right
you know you're gonna get some [ __ ] at
two in the morning if you want it
but
holy [ __ ]
you stuck
what if you get hella rich
what if what if
you know like
yeah what if you get hella rich uh
seriously that's it you know what i'm
saying look at me and he's like oh god
but what if you get hella ridge and then
you can drop your dumb
wife and marry an 18 right the wife that
emotionally supported you while you were
getting rich you were rich and you
dumper of course these guys are so
damaged sad actually it really is sad
after a certain point but
you literally aren't capable of making a
connection with another
person
truly sad and lonely
i ain't got no [ __ ] like trying to take
my cheese i'm making so much money is
stupid
like i like i mean you know what i'm
saying like bro they're all afraid of me
when you wife a [ __ ] are you afraid of
you
what do you think don't say that bubbles
because he's a powerful intimidating
alpha male
all the women in my life are afraid of
me
i'm powerful like that
damn
pray for you
bro one of them even brought me to court
she's so scared
her three friends
they ain't gonna [ __ ] me
even though they should and they would
have shiny ass heads because they just
saw their friend get wifed up with it if
i had a vagina it'd be [ __ ] dripping
i'd have sand falling out of it right
now
the dunes of [ __ ] arrakis
and you know what he he does the beard
filler
yeah like no one's what i was noticing
looks like that yeah
put makeup on before he filmed this
video 100
i think he even filled his eyebrows yeah
his eyebrows looked
microbladed
that's not very alpha
not very well that's not very alpha
behavior pretty beta carrot ring that
you put on credit
because you were tired of spending a
hundred dollars on dinner dates and
going home and jerking off i get it
because dating is hard
you got to spend a hundred dollars on
dinner for two no you know she's an
alcoholic [ __ ] which all of them are
they're gonna drink about 30 worth of
martinis or cosmos right valet the car
20.
you put cologne on you shave axe body
spray nice clothes nice shoes that's
another hundred
did he said straight up then they wanted
ice cream the pinnacle
[Laughter]
i only saved that for the finest
pro smells like a middle school hallway
ha ha for sure
for sure
this dude watched those old axe
commercials and thought they were real
you know his neck is green oh no
and he doesn't shower that much no no no
he's got like dead skin in his folds oh
like my newborn baby
you gotta get a wipe and get under there
yeah he has to suction his nose with
those little oh yeah baby booger thing
spend all that because they didn't even
eat their food that you spent a hundred
on
and then they don't want to sell you you
got a doggy bag or food right
[ __ ] are so ungrateful
i'm telling you he's got a point
also everything he's saying you don't
have to spend money on a woman to make
her like you be nice to her well
obviously his taste in women is [ __ ]
up
and you know what if he's only
surrounding himself with gold diggers
yeah then they're gonna gold dig you
don't be shocked when they do that
dating
thing we read was on a
was on a
sugar daddy website
because they can't get a date anywhere
else like wake up you gotta pay for it
wake up
i'm 20 feet tall i have a 100 000 inch
[ __ ]
i make a trillion dollars a second why
won't women i don't i don't even cook
i don't get it dick or put out because
hashtag me too told them
that it's their world
right they got the dick
you got the [ __ ]
that's what they're trying to do
that's what they're trying to do
that's why dude have you looked in the
mirror recently uh that's what i'm
saying
um we should send him a hand mirror yeah
yeah it looks like you need this bro
100
you all want me dead homie they want me
dead
i'm doing this for you
we have nobody speaking up for us
we have nobody speaking up for us oh the
downtrodden white man
straight up
stop wiping
i [ __ ] hate you
oh my god wait
chill
jesus is so scary
that other guy is more [ __ ] up
you guys have any other of the cobra guy
uh there was one other that we linked uh
if you scroll up the
tate on sparkling water
oh he's against sparkling water no way i
was like so we'll just have to see what
his take is what's what's tate's take
i'm filming in my cigar lounge this
[ __ ] has a take on sparkling
water y'all
and we're the bozos clicking on the link
that complete
but this is a room in my house that's
going to be specifically for cigars it's
a cigar lounge we've got oak on the
walls we've got very expensive liquors
not that i can tell the difference like
whiskey i bought a thousand dollars you
need to take back that you said he's
handsome i do i i retract that stability
i just want to make sure i mean it yeah
it was a flattering photo
ball tasted the same to me but that's
what you do when you're rich i've got
cigar lounge in my house because i'm a g
and that's going to lead on to the
following point that how the only water
i drink is sparkling water because
sparkling water is for real like an
idiot
right you can get non-carbonated water
still water from the [ __ ] tap
the government gives you that [ __ ]
effectively for free
sparkling water you have to buy okay so
if you only drink sparkling water you
only drink rich man's water i explain
this to someone some bro is the gassiest
person
but i don't like sparkling
you don't like sparkling water you don't
like water why does he say water he's
like he all [ __ ] up ever he speaks of
water because he's british only in
certain moments all of a sudden when you
say water you you've got to be british
also that's not how british people say
water
water water it's water water oh
beautiful
water shut the [ __ ] up oh i hate him
yeah he's the worst he actually is i
think he nicknamed himself cobra who
else named him cobra he said
he's so sick
yo that's sick that's super so sick
wow
the bubbles
you scared of bubbles you little [ __ ]
it doesn't taste of anything it has
bubbles in it or you're afraid of
yourself scared of bubbles [ __ ] you
little [ __ ]
well i'm surprised you even waste your
time thinking about sparkling water
bulls
[ __ ] is wrong with you this is another
full-grown man [ __ ] some other [ __ ]
just told you about how the [ __ ] i'm
sitting i can't go through my life
without getting angry i i've i've got to
meet people business associates etc i go
there one dude orders sushi some other
dude's scared of bubbles
dude
you need therapy like a lot of it
he goes i can't go through a i get angry
about everything it's like bingo
therapy my dude
i do have nightmares about bubbles
though yeah i'm scared you're a little
[ __ ]
if a waiter comes over and goes what
water for the table a spark plate or
water i obviously answer because i'm the
[ __ ] boss and then some little
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh can i still
the [ __ ] straight the water on the table
you're a [ __ ] man you're gonna start
making the waiter run back and forth and
change water orders because you can't
handle bubbles
[ __ ] ass dudes you should only drink
sparkling water anyways because what
aristocrats like myself
drinking who uses the term aristocrat
well the guy's obsessed with the fact
that kings were had 500 he can't get
past the
french revolution
the young napoleon
yeah if you go back far enough the
the uh caesars used to [ __ ] kids bro is
that what you want to do that was a real
sign of aristocratic back in the day put
it past him yeah he's like what you
don't [ __ ] kids you [ __ ]
that's what emperors used to do you
don't [ __ ] little boys
what are you emperor bro what are you
gay
you don't [ __ ] little boys
what are you gay
that's what makes me masculine
this is so scary have you never eaten a
little butthole
what are you gay
what's wrong with you bro dick you loved
it bro
jesus
and fishes of the sea we drink sparkling
water and you should want to be like me
because i'm a better person than you so
in every single possible tiny way you
can emulate the great andrew tate you
should be doing the same this guy cries
at night so hard
when he's alone he cries he cries stands
at a mighty five seven
oh you think he's short oh he's so tiny
no he seems tall how tall is cobra
i want to do that in his mouth
come here
watch him gag and double over pretend
it's a little kid i'm seeing six three
no way he's six three
yep he's a big cobra he just gives off
little man energy he does but he cries
when nobody's watching
same things don't order sushi drink
sparkling water wait don't order sushi
what's wrong with sushi for [ __ ] bro
[Music]
eating fish is so beta it takes too long
to prepare it doesn't you know i just
eat raw fish
mm-hmm
but even if you are such a [ __ ] you
won't choose sparkling water when it's
given to you just [ __ ] drink it if i
see a man if you ever meet a man who's
afraid of sparkling water know this he's
certainly afraid of combat i'm
who the [ __ ] is he talking to also
arguably
the opposite could be true like bro
you're drinking a fizzy drink are you a
little girl
yeah drink the [ __ ] tap water yeah
he called it government water
he called it infected government water i
love the idea of it being government
wire i
love that
how unifying
wow you're right though like drinking
fizzy water is kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] like
if if we're going with his awful lineup
yeah logic
that shirt straight from the tap and get
back to grinding right
i don't know
in the mouth he's afraid of a [ __ ]
carbonated bubble
little pussy-ass dude
at a table and your friend won't drink
sparkling water he's not your friend
because when [ __ ] hits a fan and you get
jumped and you're getting stabbed by 10
randoms he ain't jumping in front of
knives to save your ass like a good
friend should if he's scared of [ __ ]
bubbles in his water anyone who drinks
still water is excommunicated
permanently oh my god for your safety
it's hard to believe he's not kidding no
literally this is what he sounds like in
my brain if you don't do a fizzy waddle
you can't be my friend
we really like if someone wants to try
to come up to us and fight us
you're not gonna be my friend when we
have sleepovers we like to drink fizzy
water
and if you don't like the fizzy water
then you can't come to our sweet bobas
he's literally five
he's i'm five i'm just minnie
he's not five he just likes to [ __ ]
five-year-olds
like back in the day
like emperors used to do yeah
i strongly suggest you do the same get
all your friends around call every
friend you have right now all of them
invite them over for a party when they
all turn up pour out sparkling water
loyalty test
straight loyalty test bro would you
fight henry
he's like nah i'm not a fan i'll just
take the still water
[ __ ] him up boys
[Laughter]
let him have it boys the friendship test
okay
pov
you're a grown 35 year old man giving
friendship tests to your friends and
it's step one drink some fizzy water and
step two engage in hand-to-hand combat
by the way as far as hazing goes that's
like the most [ __ ] hazing ever
yeah drink the fizzy water [ __ ] drink
this bubbly meanwhile you go to frats
they're like shove this cactus up your
ass and then [ __ ]
jump off a ten foot building
and drink my pit i drink my bits from
you from a boot
pour it out see everyone let's have a
glass of water together water can't hurt
anybody we're all probably dehydrated
anyway what's the worst water can do
everyone let's have a nice glass of
water and everyone's gonna drink it and
when you see that one dude this is like
the red wedding
yeah
the red wedding on bro
drink the fizzy water rude oh
oh there's bubbles
never speak to him again nobody does
that though ever
yo i'm living for this cobra tate [ __ ]
do we have more
oh we do have more he's unbelievable i
can't believe what i'm seeing oh he's on
fresh and fit no way oh
crossover
all right and are more capable of
independent thoughts
to the left are more evolved for battle
and war if we had an idea which nobody
else agreed with we're more capable
defending it we've evolved to saying no
the sky's blue it's not green okay pull
a sword out we'll defend our idea women
don't have the capability to defend
themselves or their ideas women are
programmed they're either programmed by
society as a whole or if they're with a
good man they're programmed by the good
man that's basically where the
programming comes from as a whole
he's a scientist now facts
the young socrates is really yeah
also interestingly you know what else
socrates did [ __ ] little kids yep so he
likes that about him
i
hope
he
gets everything he's ever wished for
and then it's all taken from him
well i hope all of the fruits of his
labor turn to ash in his mouth i think
he's already living that life he all he
wanted was his mom to love him and that
didn't happen already
i i genuinely wish the worst for this
man yeah
i can we get more clips i'm living for
this
this guy is my new favorite i'm
interested show me more and i wish you
knew who michaela peterson is
who is jordan peterson i can't how do
you not know who jordan peterson is
you don't know
he's like a great right wing thinker
that's why i don't know who that is yeah
it's incredible though i mean props
wow she you may have heard about this
britney uh she was the one that kind of
went viral a couple years ago for
espousing a carnivore diet uh eating
nothing but meat
like
entirely like 100 meat literally just me
yeah and um
does she look like a [ __ ]
monster
[Laughter]
okay last one
look at him dude
look at him i don't see the point in
having female friends any real g out
there knows it's true because he's gay
right
you got the girls who you're trying to
and there ain't really room for that
chick well i don't want to ever [ __ ] him
i just want to sit here and talk and
waste his time and then he can buy me
dinner no no i'm not on i don't need
female friends if i tell a girl we're
going to [ __ ] shoot because i don't
want to say okay we don't even talk
anymore
now we ain't going to so we're going to
talk about vampire
diaries out of here
bro loves vampire diaries
why don't you pick that i'll talk about
that with my homies
right me and the boys are going to talk
about not what they caught onions though
all right that's that i guess
coney
is this guy's pony look he's got a key
2012 slay
no way but it's not coney 20 2012 it's
just kony maybe he's a supporter
he bought the merch one thing i do think
about that
he definitely jokes off to himself in
the mirror
yeah
well there you have it
so what are you up to you're doing a
podcast called uh uh we have a podcast
called violating community guidelines
and it's all about internet history
we're going to do an episode on incel
and cells actually
um
and it was kind of born out of the idea
of
i grew up online so did sarah
sarah was viral on vine and then youtube
and tick tock so she's been doing this
way longer than i have but i've been a
consumer of it for so long and i was
like there is so much
useless [ __ ] that i know a lot about
like creepypasta um fan fiction uh we
did one on um omegle and chat roulette
things like that where it's like these
kind of lost eras of the internet and i
was like if you weren't around for this
you're gonna think this is the craziest
[ __ ] ever and so we have personal
experiences talking about all of these
but we do it from like a research point
of view
so it's cool it's it's really fun so is
this available on youtube and it's
filled everywhere available everywhere
and you guys do it every week yeah every
monday episode comes out nice fun it's
good stuff and you're on um
brittany broski on
all platforms brittany underscore broski
go ahead and join broski nation we've
got a niche baby we've got healthcare we
don't it's made up
no dental vision we don't
we have no better we have no benefits
you get the benefit of calling yourself
broski nation
well this was such a fun time
you know it was really nice spending the
afternoon with you i almost peed myself
it was so funny i'm just like look at
this there's like a graveyard of
whatever the [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
i ate a whole pizza man that's insane
i think i had three pieces four pieces
they're just five penny though they're
tied they're so thin
i'm gonna finish that i know you are you
did
i know i knew you were gonna finish that
you didn't doubt me no i saw that and i
said that's thin crust he'll eat it
thank you for having me
so fun guys check out brittany thank you
guys for watching it's friday right
friday baby
friday baby
we have any show announcements dan to
make
um should we no
no i mean they'd be saying no why you
say no so fast
well because i heard from
someone who represents that person
because we we have we have cursed luck
when we announce it that's why we have a
guest
potentially potentially next friday
what's the t yeah what's the team why
are you
okay
okay
idubbbz might be here now i don't yeah
to uh talk about the fight and
everything but yeah now that we said
that uh it's not to work out yeah so
thank you brittany bob
all right guys thanks for watching brand
new thank you for coming so much fun
saying to the camera [ __ ] rhett link for
me i don't think i will
i tried
i'm serious they sexually assaulted me
they came in and showed me their [ __ ]
and nobody believes
[Music]